for specified costs uh to be
administered as we understand through
the Department of Labor I and we've
heard a little bit about some of the
rationale uh as to why um in part as I
understand because of the Department's
um connection with with Workforce so I
do just want to take a moment to kind of
maybe explain a little bit about what
the Department of Labor does primarily
do and we are called the Department of
Labor the majority of our uh role uh
really the sole role that the department
has is in the context of regulation of
employers
uh and insurance carriers as it relates
to workers compensation the workers
compensation scheme uh for employers
across the state uh and Employers in
certain compliance with uh primarily
wage W what we would call wage laws are
employees working are they getting paid
in time recordkeeping related to that is
minimum wage being paid when appropriate
over time um those types of issues and
then also some occupational safety um
area so this this program would be
somewhat different than the types of
program uh really we don't have any
programs this would be um a very
different type of program uh to for the
Department one that we we don't have
something similar to currently um we
don't administer any other types of
Grant programs we don't uh have grants
that funnel uh through our agency
currently um kind of as some technical
points and just sort of looking at the
structure of the bill itself number one
were this language to go into effect we
would really recommend uh creating a
whole new section um right now it's
placed within
27584 which is uh relative to protective
legislation outlining certain
requirements for employers as it relates
to recordkeeping and and hours worked
and things of that nature this probably
would um more likely than not would uh
be more appropriately placed perhaps as
a 275 DJ um as its own section separate
from protective legislation um in
addition the department would note that
there is nothing uh within the proposed
language giving it rule making Authority
and it would be our it is our
understanding from the proposed language
that given that this grant program would
be funneling through the department we
would be having some form of oversight
in relation to it and we believe in
order to do that adequately we would
need the ability to make rules um as to
the language itself that's been proposed
a couple of um areas that we would note
um you know number one if we look at
provision two at line 13 it's uh having
the department in consultation with the
advisory Council on Child Care um work
on designating an entity to uh
administer the Recruitment and Retention
of the grants that are associated with
this program um we're a little bit
unclear as to what that would look like
um or sort of how that would be uh
facilitated as well as how it would be
funded there's not a funding mechanism
that's outlined within the proposed
legislation as to how this entity is
going to get um paid for the services uh
that it's making um or that it's going
to be uh providing um and we're not
really certain how the designation would
work it we would assume it would go
through the um or it seems like it could
go through the routine procurement
processes but we don't know if the
intent uh you know what the intent there
um necessarily uh is um so we think
those are are some pieces to be um to be
aware of um and then as it relates to
the to the funding itself that's going
to be going into the grant program um
it's our understanding that the funding
can come from several different points
as as drafted in the proposed language
private state or federal monies um but
it's not really specified currently so
that seems
somewhat uh somewhat broad so we do
understand from talking with Early
Learning New Hampshire that there is an
idea or an intent there that within the
first year or so of the program that the
funding sources are going to be be
explored um but we're not really certain
what the Department's role would then be
and reaching you know securing grants or
anything of that matter and and we don't
as I noted we don't have Grant programs
that we currently administer it's really
not an area that we have uh expertise or
staff already working on um we didn't
have the opportunity to do a fiscal note
we weren't asked to do a fiscal note on
this particular Bill we've not really
had the chance to look at what kind of
costs would be Associated for the
Department in relation to administering
this program we do think that's
something that the department would need
to look at and explore especially given
that we don't have a current uh similar
program that we're administering uh in
which we could relate it to um but I am
happy to take any questions if you have
any um and I'm more than happy to
continue working with the committee and
and with the
sponsors if the um in looking towards
what could be workable again we do
understand that there's an expressed um
need here for this type of of program
and we do understand that so we're happy
to work going forward on any of
that questions from the committee yeses
deimon thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question how much lead time would you
need to be able to set up the criteria
necessary to be accepting These funds if
that's what happens I think that's an
excellent question and I'm not sure that
the department is really in a spot right
now to make even a ballpark assessment
of that I mean I I would
imagine doing it off the C six months if
not a little bit more again this would
be a completely new area for us and
we've only just had a chance to look at
this language um as of yesterday um so I
do think that is something that the
department would need to explore in
order to even get you a a really good
time frame as to how long would we need
to to
determine what we would need to
administer it um it is very outside this
um very different than anything that
we're doing right now just followup of
course follow up thank you for the
followup just so is it fair to say that
you would need at least six or more
months lead time at least if not more
but yes thank you again hard to nail
down a specific time frame at this
juncture I think um further questions
from the committee representative
crean thank you chair thank you for
taking my question
um I'm not sure that you're the best
person to answer this question but so
given that the Department of Labor
doesn't have the expertise are you aware
of another department in the state that
you think would be better suited or um
do you think it's something that would
be appropriate here but just would
require a stretch I mean I think
ultimately at the thank you for the
question and I think at the end of the
day you know the it it really is on the
committee to determine where the
appropriate department is I mean there
are other departments within the state
system that have involvement um not just
with child care regulation I I believe
DHHS has some programs in relation to
you know licensing of child care
facilities there are other state
agencies that do Workforce Development
the Department of Labor does not engage
in Workforce Development we don't engage
with employees in that way um the Bureau
of economic Affairs does a lot of
Workforce Development um New Hampshire
employment security does um some form
forms of work work uh placement with
individuals through their unemployment
program although I would defer to un uh
Unemployment Security on the mechanics
behind that I believe they also May
administer certain types of Grant
programs um whereas the department the
Department of Labor currently does not
you're
welcome further questions uh I
definitely have some um I I know you
just saw this yesterday um is there any
insight as to why do was chosen for this
and not
I'm sure somebody will answer that
question and not not normally DHHS is
what trial centers deal with um was
there any any insight given to you on
that yeah yes thank you for the question
so we did have the opportunity to speak
with learning um Early Learning New
Hampshire and our understanding is that
uh labor was chosen because we are the
Department of Labor and have a
connection to the workforce um we you
know we do have um some laws that we
have jurisdiction over as it relates to
to apprenticeship programs I would note
the Department's role within those
programs is
relatively um slim as the US Department
of Labor so on the federal side um
handles more of the apprenticeship uh
pieces um so very little involvement
from the State Department of Labor in
that context but that's our our general
understanding that it seemed to um to
the to those involved to be a good fit
because of that connection and I'm sure
they could speak to that probably a lot
more eloquently
I I can almost assure you someone will
answer that question
um uh so this bill doesn't establish the
actual monetary money that goes into the
fund that's my understanding um so and I
know you haven't had a chance to prepare
a fiscal note but
obviously let's say we pass this thing
it becomes law there's no fiscal
apportionment to it we're outside of the
budget time so there's no money until
next year at the earliest but would the
department then incur a cost regardless
of whether or not the the program is
funded or not just to try to set it up
thank you for the question I I IM it's
possible that we could again we've not
really had a chance to look at it um but
as I noted it's our understanding that
while you know that if the intent is for
this grant program to pass through us
and again it's our understanding that
the idea or intent is this designated
entity is going to be doing the primary
Administration but number one we would
have to make rules and regulations in
relation to that um you know we would
have ad administrative as well as
Financial oversight I mean I think the
LBA is going to you know require the
department to be able to go in and do
some forms of financial audit as well as
administrative oversight of how this is
being administered um so you know one we
would have to set that up it would take
some time in order for us to get rules
going so um and as I said we don't have
Grant programs currently um I think
there would be some staffing costs in
relation to that Financial oversight um
I I don't know that we I don't know at
this point whether or not additional
staff would be needed but it may be
possible um I think we would really have
to look at that in order to determine
what that one what would that cost be
what would it look like how would that
impact you know what would that impact
be but I think it we would have to to
look at that I think it's fair to say
that there could
be okay um I may bring you back up here
just at some point just by so you could
hang around um I think there's going to
be more questions thank you so much
sorry there's no other questions in the
committee right I I was okay all right
cool thank you um next up uh lyanna
Lorden good morning um to start I'd like
to thank you all for your time and
allowing me to testify um I'm here today
in support of um hb1 1611 and appreciate
your consideration as this is my first
time testifying so I'll try to talk slow
not being nervous cuz you're all regular
people um so my name is Lanna Lorden and
I'm the chief operating officer at White
birge Center in hener for the past 13
years I've been directly involved with
the management of two child care
programs these programs serve children
ages 9 months to 14 years of age with a
combined license capacity of 160 over my
time with white birch I've been able to
see the industry EB and flow um one
example I'd like to share with you is
from 5 years ago our agency hosted a
focus group um following our greatest
bout of turnover to date with 40% of our
staff turning over um
while it's okay take your time you're
fine you're fine
um while participating in this Focus
group um it was one of the hardest days
on the job for me um it was incredibly
eye openening um because it really
highlighted that our agency and the
industry needed to put forth um more
efforts in the area of Recruitment and
Retention and again this was five years
ago um for our employees our clients
families and
children um by addressing these
challenges the outcomes for children
families and the workforce were improve
approved but they need continual
attention and investment and we're
currently still doing so this is this
was very challenging and still is today
for small businesses nonprofit
organizations who must compete with
larger businesses and budgets for top
talent and
programs and additionally while the
pandemic reinforced and deepened public
understanding of the essential role of
Early Child Care and education working
families and the economy it didn't
address the systemic shortcomings that
have plagued um the above entities for
years and ultimately A system that has
been deeply underfunded and undervalued
another example um in 2019 the median
wage for childcare workers in New
Hampshire was
$11.69 for preschool teachers the median
wage um was
$14.43 and in New Hampshire early
Educators with a bachelor's degree are
paid 22 and a half% less than their
colleagues in a K through 8 public
school system
that last statistic really resonated
with me and still does today as I hold a
bachelor's degree in elementary
education and a current teaching
certificate for K through 8 in public
school and I've experienced those lower
wages compared to my colleagues even
more so when I began in this field back
in 2010 it was solely because there
weren't any District positions um I left
teaching fifth grade because again there
wasn't any District positions so I had
to settle or so I thought um for a
toddler classroom teaching position at
White Birch where I am today that
opportunity however had a incredibly
Silver Lining um leading me straight to
where I am today um so little tead
because this is a passion of mine and um
I do appreciate your time and urge you
to pass um HB 1611 thank you again for
your time and consideration okay would
you like to take any questions from the
committee happy to are there any
questions from the committee saying none
thank you thank you next up is oh I'm
sorry do you have any written testimony
oh do you have written testimony would
you like to submit your written
testimony
sure that's fine you can email it to us
it's fine or you can give it to us
that's whatever you want
um next up is Lynn
wette good morning um I'd like to say
thank you to all of you for giving us
your time and attention um this is a
very important issue on the floor
um I've am the my name is Lyn wette I'm
the director of Nelly's treehouse in
Amis New Hampshire um we have a
enrollment of 69 children um and um I am
also part of the child care advisory
Council um this is a passion it's my
career um and so um I for a great
example of what happens yesterday
morning I was hit with hi I need to give
you my notice I'm going to teach in
Massachusetts because I can make more
money and I'm giving you one week um I
have six babies who are going to lose
their teacher in one
week um I will make it work my families
come
first and it's really important that we
find a way to pay these teachers a
livable decent wage so that they don't
look it somewhere else and go oh I can
make more money there um and to top that
off that classroom is only half full
because we have been searching for a
teacher for eight
months um those children in that
classroom also have siblings in my
school and I will tell you my waiting
list doubles my enrollment at this time
um and that is phone call after phone
call week after week do you have
anything is something available did you
hire a staff and I'm pretty honest with
people
um we have raised our staff um pay as
high as we possibly can without having
to raise our prices so that parents
can't afford them um and I think it's
really important that we look at this
field as a career as
education and we need to make sure that
these people these the staff this
Workforce who supports the workforce for
every other business in the
state is is given an opportunity to make
a livable wage and have benefits to
support them so that they can they don't
have to worry about can I afford my rent
this month um and I hear that from my
staff we actually have a fund setup to
try to help people when they're in an
emergency um you know they're important
to us um and our children deserve the
best in consistency and when we can't
pay people well and they move over to
Target because they can make $20 an hour
our kids are not our children are are
lacking
consistency and in all honesty that
affects our Workforce because a mom who
goes to work and doesn't know who her
child is going to have for a teacher
because the teacher called out or we're
looking for a new staff member can't
focus on their work to do their job well
um so we do our best to make sure that
we are consistent um I can tell you in
the 41 years I've done this I have spent
more time was a director in a
classroom um than I did when I was a
teacher probably um and I I will not
argue with you I love every last minute
of it but we need to make sure that our
youngest children and our families are
getting the best we possibly can do and
that means
acknowledging that our child care
Workforce is really important not just
to our parents and our families but also
to the economy of our states um and so I
thank you for taking time um and
hopefully your
pass okay question will you be taking
questions sure all right and are there
questions seeing none thank you thank
you all right next up uh name I'm very
familiar with Mr will Stewart It's good
to see
you thank you Mr
chairman excuse me members of the
committee for the record my name is Will
Stewart and I'm the executive director
of stay workpl New Hampshire which is a
Statewide nonprofit whose mission is the
attraction and retention of young people
here in the granite state and here today
in full support of House Bill 1611 in
the amendment um because we recognize at
stay work play you know through our data
collection uh primarily that child care
is you know probably maybe only second
to housing a very close second you know
one of the biggest challenges facing
young people who want to start families
here in New Hampshire uh we do you know
formal surveys you know through um
institutions of Higher Learning here in
the state and at present we're going all
around the state eight locations talking
to young people and uh you asking them
you know what makes it challenging to
live in New Hampshire and also what do
you like and you know I'm struck by a
comment uh Jackie cow from Early
Learning New Hampshire has heard me say
this uh a number of times um but by a
comment that we heard in the Upper
Valley that it was specific to the Upper
Valley but I think is it applies to New
Hampshire RIT large and this young woman
said she said the Upper Valley is a
wonderful place to raise a family but
it's a very very very challenging place
to start one and I think that you know
really speaks uh in large measure you
know to you know how great New Hampshire
really is you know for young people to
have a career to be able to raise a
family um but it's incredibly difficult
to do so to get that tow hold here and
child care costs we hear it you know
both we see it in the data and we hear
it anecdotally in all the conversations
we have all across the state um so for
that reason you know we are looking at
any and all you know possible measures
you know to help make child care more
affordable for our families you know so
that not only the businesses that we
have here have the employees they need
to do the jobs but they communities have
the people they need to step up and
volunteer at our state and local boards
and that um you know that our our kids
our children you know have the uh you
know the the oversight and um that they
need so I'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee might
have are there questions from the
committee thank you for preempting me on
that
one okay seeing none thank you thank
you next up is going to be Jackie cow
with early learning new New Hampshire I
don't know why I said an H like a weirdo
but good morning how do you do I'm
Jackie Cowell um from uh Early Learning
New Hampshire we are a Statewide
nonprofit organization um committed to
um ensuring the Next Generation Um has
the opportunities they need to reach
their full potential and we do that
primarily around childcare and um both
membership services for child care
programs um uh and advocacy for both the
families they serve as well as the pro
you know the programs and their
Workforce and we also do some public
awareness raising around the importance
of the early years so um um also just
want to thank you um for all the work
you did last year as well to really
delve into the issue and to hear what
the issues were and I and I'm glad we're
here again um coming up with some of the
solutions um we um are in support of um
House Bill 1611 we think it's um it's
it's based on what we tried to do last
year as you might remember there was a
Senate Bill
237 that was um there and it um did a
lot of terrific um Family Access uh
policy changes that are really going to
be very helpful to the hardworking um
parents here in New Hampshire to afford
childcare we're very pleased that that
was there in that bill as well which
ended up been hb2 but in that bill as
well was um asking for an ongoing
allocation to support the retention and
recruitment of the childcare Workforce
in the form of Grants ongoing grants
every year the main reason for that is
again to raise the earnings the
compensation the benefits of the
childcare Workforce to keep them there
and attract them without going back
simply to the families they serve
because right now that's where it's
coming from they don't have it you know
at and and sometimes I'm asked the
question which which is more important
act affordability for families and um or
you know a strong stable Workforce and
it seems like it's a hard question right
like which which do you pay attention to
which do you invest in well frankly if
you don't have that strong stable
Workforce you know affording an empty
classroom does you no good and so that's
really what we're trying to prioritize
here and so when thinking about this
year so they did do a one-time
allocation of 15 million from General
funds um but they did not establish a
childcare Workforce fund because it was
a one-time allocation and thinking about
what we needed to do this year in
preparation for next budget year um
speaking with many other um folks
including Senator Jeb Bradley who asked
you know this is a good year to
establish the workforce fund work on
getting it together get that
infrastructure in place and then ask for
some funding to go into it in a budget
year so that is the plan um and then but
it does allow any bud any items to go
into it in talking with um commissioner
marfield Deputy Commissioner Albert and
her team their team we did actually go
to many different Commissioners to talk
about this
fund DHHS has a lot on their plate they
are really working hard to get the
family affordability policies in place
there's a lot of work to be done they
have not they do not do grants directly
to employees they do it to employers and
the childcare community did say with the
payroll tax and all the other things you
know it would be a benef benefit if the
grants go directly to the employee
that's how this is set up that was a
direct request from the Child Care
community and we did talk to
commissioner Taylor Caswell um about
this and he was great and he applauds it
but thought you know actually he thought
Bea was not necessarily the best place
and talking to other Commissioners we
did talk to commissioner katus and
Deputy Commissioner labors we did talk
to commissioner um marfield and frankly
I felt knowing what the childcare
Community needs and and wants Department
of Labor and commissioner maryel as a
partner just seems so logical yes I
understand that they don't do a grant
program the idea for this though is
there the regulatory Agency on the side
of workers right you know so so it seems
so logical for us to really partner with
them and also to make that strong
statement about how Child Care supports
the labor forces all labor forces not
just so that was the primary reason we
started those conversations with the
Department of Labor are eager to look at
how this is unprecedented to having a
grant go out to the employee like this
for this essential Workforce so
yeah will we be taking questions I
assume so yes represent
Phillips my apologies for being late
thank you for taking my question um so I
uh I'm just joining in and I'm reviewing
the amendment too but I'm interested in
if you would support or maybe this
sponsors have considered like a sunset
on this so say we actually solve this
miracle crisis of child care and we have
an abundance all of a sudden of child
care workers who are being paid and we
now have too many people who want to
work in this so I just so as a as a
fiscal conservative right this the the
angle is that is there is there some
sort of metric where you would say 5
years from now if we can frontload all
of these good workers getting young kids
out of high school to come and want to
work in childcare um is there a a a year
or anount years or some sort of place
where we could put a sunset on this and
then dismiss this I think that's a
terrific discussion to have I mean you
don't want it there if you don't need it
at the same time what we do know is that
a person working in childcare child care
professional earns less than half a um
per year than a public school teacher
for instance and has no retirement
benefits and has no blah blah blah blah
right so but I would be certainly
willing to to think about what that
could look like you know if you get to
this point is the fund needed because
again what we're trying to do is again
have the the state investment saying why
they're investing and you know why this
Workforce as we mentioned um we might
not have mentioned it yet but for every
one childcare teacher it supports about
eight different um children in the you
know to be able to be there who then
have maybe you know maybe you know 10 to
16 parents so it's really like all
Industries it's having trouble but this
one is a little different because it
allows the other Industries to go to
work so I think that's a conversation we
could have what does it look like that
it's enough right so yeah thank you
representative
Paige thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so just thinking
about where this sits
administratively I appreciate you kind
of helping us through your process
understanding sort of the process of
elimination you went through that landed
you at the Department of Labor y um can
you tell me a little bit more
about the conversations you had with the
other Commissioners um their concerns
about having it sit with them that
eventually LED you to labor because we
hearing from Lab the department of labor
today it's you know we're trying to
figure out what the right place to house
it is and it's helpful like excellent if
T if commissioner Caswell had concerns
why doesn't it live with ba Etc and to
be honest I don't think he had concerns
about the grants or the workforce fund
just felt maybe a different agency it
was as simple as that it wasn't anything
in depth about that we don't do this or
we won't do this or we have enough work
uh I think it was really
um when we mentioned who we were else
who were talking said oh yeah that
sounds logical honestly and to be frank
it was it was commissioner marold and
our and our conversation with it felt
like such a strong partnership
possibility here in the way that he he's
got a strong team over there even though
you know they haven't done this before I
know this can be crafted in a way that's
really again it's the first time doing
it this way so it does have to be built
together
yeah okay uh further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you
um next up
is Robert M McLoud yes nailed it all
right Cloud thank you I have a written
testimony I'll give that to you after
I'm
done good morning uh committee uh my
name is Bob McLoud I'm sort of in a
unique situation here I am the CEO of
Midstate Health Center uh we have uh
four locations in uh four different
communities we serve 29 communities um
in central uh New Hampshire um my core
business of course is primary care
Behavioral Health dental
infusion um physical therapy and
Specialty Services I'm here today take a
a few moments out of my schedule to talk
about uh child care one of the gems in
our Crown at Midstate is that we have a
we have 60 Children daycare center
called little antlers I've been on
Channel 9 a couple of times touting that
um and we get great reviews from our
federal delegation as well as our uh
local delegation as well um we have some
advantages that some of the other
daycare centers don't have which is that
uh we do give our staff a pension we do
give them health insurance and we do
give them uh free tuition if they have a
child uh in our daycare center however
we pay around 17 or maybe $18 an hour
and over the past uh three or four
months out of a staff of 15 full-time
and part-time we had it uh we lost four
staff members which really um impacts
our ability to staff the U uh the
agency um so
use me as an example I have some of the
stuff that's written in this in this
legislation and it's still not enough
there are times when I could testify and
say money doesn't solve a problem here's
an instance where money does solve the
problem it's $17 an hour $18 an hour
many of these folks are single single
parents or they they don't have another
source of income one of my assistant
directors works at Mar
to augment her her income now a lot of
us do Moonlight and but the fact of the
matter is they have to work a second job
to make things to make things work
irrespective of what agency finally
handles this what a shame to lose at
least this first step in the opportunity
to make things better and remember this
legislation is just the first step it
creates the pot there's no money in it
it just creates the pot and um I can't
tell you firmly enough and I've
testified uh Jackie knows I've been at
some of her things here um please this
is so vitally important you know when we
we thought about opening this I talked
to the local hospital they didn't want
to do anything with us I talked to
businesses they didn't want to do
anything with us and every year that we
have this open it costs us us Midstate
$100,000 plus a year to subsidize this
and that's at a wage of $17 an
hour and we have 60 kids now we're
licensed for a 100 I'll never see it
because we'll never have enough staff
because we don't pay enough in there's
too much competition elsewhere and
what's really troubling about this uh
committee members is that this trickles
all the way through the community people
can't find uh employeers can't find
people to do their jobs because they
have to take care of their children and
and to me this is an this is the first
step of a greater opportunity to make a
difference without a huge impact on the
state budget so I humbly say please
consider this let this legislation pass
figure out who the agency that's going
to handle it don't let that stand in the
way get this thing done I strongly
recommend that uh you move this thing uh
forward so thank you very very much um
I'm just a cranky all guy just here
testifying uh so but thank you very very
much and I appreciate your time and I I
am here to answer any questions thank
you I'm a cranky sort of younger
guy um any other questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you thank you uh last up is Amanda Sears
with the campaign for familyfriendly
economy
hello you're not Amanda I am Amanda
you're Amanda geez I'm sorry told you I
haven't had my coffee yet I haven't had
much coffee either but I think I am you
are you are Amanda I can confirm you are
Amanda uh hi uh I am Amanda sear I am
the New Hampshire state director for the
campaign for a familyfriendly economy we
are uh based here in New Hampshire
working to advance policies and and
build support for um efforts that can
help families to make ends meet and be
there for their families when they need
to be and so Child Care is of course a
central part of what we work to advance
um I want to thank you for um
considering this bill and I also want to
thank you I didn't look up your voting
history but I bet many of you voted for
the budget um last year that included um
the 15 million dollar that some people
before me have spoken about to um to
help with a one-time expenditure um in
Workforce Workforce support what I think
is really um helpful about this bill is
that in a non-budget year it gives an
opportunity to think about we do we do
still need this kind of resource and
this kind of support but where does it
really belong and how do we get it to um
be structured in such a way that it can
work that the most efficiently and best
that it can I really appreciate the
Department of Health and Human Services
for working to get these this money out
the door I think that it is still in
process there they have a lot you know
it's an enormous department they have a
lot on their plate and I think it's sat
with them because they do so much else
on child care with the child care
scholarship program and Licensing but
this is really a business and economic
development program this Workforce fund
it's not like the other child care
programs that they run which are you
know about scholarships to families that
need assistance Etc this is looking to
solve a problem that businesses have now
and that is our Workforce crisis I am
sure that when each and every one of you
is talking to people in your your
districts you are hearing about the
workforce crisis from Employers in your
districts um everybody is struggling to
find workers the reason to invest in the
child care sector um when everybody is
looking for workers is because the
single largest factor keeping people who
are outside of the workforce from
working right now is access to care um
and so we could have additional people
entering our Workforce if they could get
off of the weight list that you've heard
about from some of the child care
centers here and had care for their um
for their little ones
and so this is a um way to get more
people not only working in the child
care sector but working in all of our
sectors and so that's why it's really a
business and economic development
program so I do hope that as you're
considering this bill what you're
considering is what the right home for
it is not whether we need it so I I
appreciated um you know representative
your comment that you know that's part
of what you're thinking about and
deliberating is is what is the right
home because I think that's really the
question and so I hope that um and I
think that you know I know you don't
have a lot of time but in an in a
non-budget year you have a little bit
more time to consider that piece so that
then next year when it's another budget
year you're able to consider and what
can we put toward that you know and and
think about what the right amount of
resources are within the context of the
funding plan for the whole state and and
the resources um that you're considering
as part of the budget so thank you and
I'll take any questions okay questions
from the
committee seeing none that's it um uh
can you some my grab the blue sheet for
me for this um I always forget to do
that I remember the unlike the one chair
that remembers the online and I always
forget the blue sheet um okay so online
uh pretty lopsided 895 logged in support
and seven
opposed
um and then in
person um one person signed up to speak
one person signed in that didn't speak
in support um so with that going to
close the public hearing in on House
Bill um
1611 um committee is going to stand in
recess for 5 minutes while I talk to the
ranking member real quick
okay you are so good
awesome
happen um the rules allow us to execu
Bill immediately after hearing it with
the consent of the ranking member um so
we're going to begin executive session
on a house bill 611 FN
uh with the consent of the ranking
member uh R wner do I have your consent
to begin the executive session you don't
take a vote we're not I I can't I can't
say that but so long as do I have your
ability do we have your consent to take
the exec okay so okay so we're now on
discussion we're now on discussion uh on
the bill what I would like to do is work
directly off of uh uh representative MC
Williams amendment I don't want to adopt
the amendment because then we're going
to adopt Amendment an adopted Amendment
and adopted Amendment so we're just
going to we're going to act I if we're
all in agreement we're going to act as
if this is the bill currently okay um so
let me start off with um my kind of
concerns um I do not like the Department
of Labor for this um I know that's not
going to be the most popular statement
in the world and I I I was telling my
colleagues I can't believe I'd ever say
these words I actually think DHHS should
handle this and that you should write
this day down um cuz we haven't always
haven't always gotten along with them
and that's okay um but I do believe they
are actually the proper Agency for it um
the other thing is is when you go down
and you start looking at these
benefits uh with the exception of um the
student loan repayment these are all
benefits that normally flow from the
employer um the purpose of putting it in
the department of labor was to have it
flow directly to the employee um I am
not a huge fan fan of that um I'm happy
to Aline about why I'm not a huge fan of
that but in my in my mind it effectively
makes them kind of Quasi state employees
to an extent um I would rather if we are
going to do something like this have the
the the student loan repayment like just
an FYI like from the Republican side of
the cogress that's going to have to come
off like we're not going to be in the
business of having the government repay
student loans it's a whole thing I'm
sorry everything else is actually very
common employer benefit
so what I would rather see is some sort
of system where this fund is established
right and then the employers can emplo
the employers which you define in the
backs side of your amendment can then
apply for direct reimbursement of proven
costs right um so right now they fill
out you know we fill out the CCO Grant
and all sort of stuff at the end of the
year um we could find a way for the DHHS
to set up this system where it's like
all right we have a certain amount of
funds allocated you know certain amount
and you prove these costs and then has
to be direct repayment of those proven
costs not what you think the costs will
be but what the costs actually are um
the other thing that we we by by we I
mean the Republican side of the aisle um
we are not going to start preferencing
certain Child Care Centers over others
um I know that there is a desire to pick
child care centers that take the state
scholarship over ones that don't we're
not our side's not going to get on board
with that we treat everybody the same
I'm not aware of Child Care Center that
doesn't take the child care center
scholarship um I'm sure there are some
um but the overwhelming vast majority do
but I'm defin for the record mine does
um but I I do not want to get into the
business of effectively picking winners
and losers because they do something we
like or something we don't like so that
is kind of my um opening Salvo of my
thoughts on this um and and those things
which I think keeps the underlying
intent of the bill there it keeps
probably for being honest 90% of the
bill there um but makes it um I think
Much More pwle Much More functioning um
and doesn't have child private Child
Care employees going to the state of New
Hampshire Department of Labor for
reimbursement of a benefit that I don't
know how they would like how would they
prove they got PTO or they didn't get
PTO you you can see like these questions
arising it's these are all employer
benefits just have them flow through the
employer have it come from DHHS there's
no reason to have the CH the child care
center uh child care provider work with
a new Department um and that's that's
kind of my thoughts on it so definitely
that was a lot so representative MC
Williams uh thank you very much for
outlining your concerns with the bill
chair Barry um I think that regardless
of who the agency is I'm pretty agnostic
about that specific thing I'll let my
other colleagues speak if they have
strong thoughts about it but I think
having a good administrator is more
important than having it be a specific
administrator um so that being said I
think that that's okay um I understand
your concerns about most of these being
things that flow through the employer
except for student loan repayment and so
I would raise you instead of student
loan repayment can we talk about um
reimbursement for related Education
costs because there's always continuing
ad each year um so any any of those that
can be proven with a receipt right
because you had said that you wanted to
have proven costs after the fact so I
would say education um with related
education with receipt obviously you
can't go become a plumber while you're
working for a child care center and get
your education reimbursed there but um I
think that that at least it's in the
spirit of you spent some money on
education and we'd like to make sure
that you can stay uh in the career that
you've chosen with the education costs
that you've incurred um and then finally
you said you don't want them enrolled in
the Department of Health and Human
Services child care scholarship program
um I don't know how important that is
Mis interpreting I don't want so there's
a clause in in the B that uh as the
funds get exhausted they're preferenced
I don't want I don't want any preference
okay um because because it's it's you
actually because when I first read it I
I misunderstood it but you basically
giving this to every child care center
in the state effectively cuz you have
number two is a catchall nonprofit and
privately owned Center based and family
based childcare programs right y um
which you probably actually could
probably just be number two number that
could be it on its own um what we don't
want is the preference it's it's uh so
just remove b b on second page just take
out B um take out B I think the rest of
it's fine okay um that's fine and then I
actually like your proposition on the
student loan because as I've said before
in our hearings you know getting these
teachers into Lead Teacher positions
requires a CDA that's roughly about
$500 um that's right in line with what
we're looking to do um so and that's
again it's a proven cost after the fact
um as a a something that very well
easily could once again flow through the
employer we could we call that related
education expenses yeah sure yeah yeah
Prov yeah proven continuing education
costs or something like
that representative crean thank you um I
will just throw out there as someone
who's kind of tangentially involved in
HR and recruiting and things in my uh
day job uh student loan repayment is
definitely something that is becoming
more popular as um something that's
offered and um through employers as as
you mentioned so um I don't necessarily
have strong opinions about taking it out
or leaving it in but uh I just did want
to throw that out there and then my
other question was um if we get rid of
42b um do we need to replace it with any
other language about uh what to do if
requests succeed of available funding
like make it first come first served or
yeah yeah that's definitely a good point
um because I think the other thing is is
how is
this there's there's an imaginative pot
pot of money right we don't know what
the pot of money is um that was a
concern that my cus was willing to
overlook just FYI um but there's this
magic there's this imaginary pot of
money that doesn't yet exist and might
might not ever exist who knows um the
question is is how is it allocated right
so does it if we don't set up some sort
of structure we don't allow DHS to set
up some sort of regulated structure
there's going to be this massive Jan one
go to the well as quickly as you can um
versus you know kind of what they do
effectively with the other grants that
they Dole out um which is it's usually
based on like um not well one of is not
even based on act R one's based on alloc
um capacity um but that would be
something that the HH like I would be in
favor of some structure where it was
based on in enrollment um I really don't
like doing it based on capacity I
actually like doing it based on
enrollment um and then um and just have
it be divvied up proportionally um and
then some clause about what to do with
unexpended funds in the back in the last
quarter of the year now we're getting
really into the fiscal weeds um but
you'd have to figure out something to do
with unexpended funds at the end of the
year or you just leave it in there and
let it be invested and and the interest
rolls back into the accounts but that's
a question for our good friends at
fiscal yes representative wner some of
those things I think would be inter
um if we in we do need to include in
here that the department no matter what
department it is can promate rules so a
lot of the things that you just
mentioned would be in the promation of
the rules um that whoever whichever
Department it is um has
it I guess I know that I'm trying to
imagine the kind of administrative
structure we're going going to need if
we're having every child care provider
in the state giving receipts to someone
to be reimbursed it is going to be I
think an enormous administrative
structure and I'm not sure that anyone
is ready for that um I think the idea
behind this was that there would be that
Tri care providers would be eligible for
a grant and then these are the ways they
could use it and that they wouldn't be
sending in individual receipts because I
think that's going to be
administratively very difficult for
anyone um any department or any entity
to really manage that kind of that kind
of system um so I do have a question
that I might want to ask somebody in the
audience if you would allow that yeah my
first let me respond to that um if you
don't have some sort of system about
proven cost then you're just giving them
money right and and and can raise their
hand and say I I swear I'm using this
for student loan repayment or talk where
discount um they can you know but the
reality is is like I know how money
works and if you give somebody a check
and you don't say show me the receipts
they may or may not do with that money
what you want them to do and that's just
human like that's just human nature like
I'm sorry um you know I that's that's
one of the reasons I want I think it's
actually more appropriate to go through
the employer um is it's just you're just
I mean at that point from effectively
you're saying like why don't we just
give child providers Child Care actual
workers money um it would be a lot
easier just to be like here's you know
here's five grand have a great day you
know see you next January um and I I
that's something that we were we're
never getting on board with that so um
but anyways yeah who do you want to hear
from the audience representative War
well I'm not I'm not really sure I'm
looking out there in the audience I just
want to know if anyone has any
information about this I know that there
have been many states in the United
States have already set up Grant
programs for child care providers and I
just wondered if someone might say
something about what what departments if
you know what departments are running
those and to if they are direct grants
or if they're doing a receipt kind of
process and hi again I'm Jackie cow from
Early Learning New Hampshire um I think
part of what we as a as a field as a
group of um Co ition members here
talking directly with the field both to
employers and to employees was really
trying to do something that we thought
would be most effective and that was
again the employers were saying they've
got enough on their plate they don't you
know some some again you know studying
retention it's it can be very particular
to what this particular employee needs
they may or may not need health
insurance they may or may not once you
start having the employer doing all
these benefits um this isn't actually
affecting their operating supports right
this is a grant to really raise the
earnings of individual childcare
employees to keep them there and the
intent you know again designing it with
you know Department of Labor and others
is there's there are studies that show
if there's a couple of Grants a year
it's better than the $5,000 in the
beginning of the year thank you very
much good luck you know it's you know it
really is that if you do if you do again
if you have certain amount of money and
you figure out um what it would be per
employee those employees can apply for
that Grant perhap probably three times a
year that tends to keep retention
knowing they're going to be able to
access money in this month and then that
month and that month then you would you
know you could also have some states
have done things why you know you have
to stay in the job or you have pay them
because they did stay in the job for the
last four months right you verify that
you've been in the job for the last four
months you've been doing this you're a
full-time employee this is the stip and
you're earning how are you planning on
do on using that money for what your
need is now figuring out you know again
trying to figure out the best way for
accountability without having it Stacks
and stacks and stacks and receipts and
receipts but the idea really was again
to to administer these grants on an
ongoing basis is in a very simple way to
to access online and do their
application Survey Monkey whatever it is
do their applications online their
verifications online but also having
really really good ta really having
we've learned with a lot of the grants
that have gone out and you know
representative Barry better than anyone
else at this table too how tough it can
be to understand what the what the
grants are about some people are not
even applying because they're not sure
we really don't want that to happen to
the workforce and you add that extra
layer of employer and I understand the
reasoning of that but I really think you
know we we really felt based on the on
the information from the field
that if these could be employee grants
other states have done it in different
ways um Maryann behind me knows a little
bit more Washington DC did a stipend of
$10,000 a year from a fund that they
were able to access there's different
ways of doing it main did $200 a month
you know um but it really was for the
employees some of them I think did go to
the
employer so but yeah thank you um yeah
you know so going back to this like I
think it's like if you give people PTO
well that's a tax liability now because
PTO is a PTO is a a pay it's money so
you know how how are we accounting you
know or is this you can see all these
questions that get opened up right is
the state going to withhold the seven
the state going to withhold the employer
side and the employee side on the PTO
benefit that's being dled out right like
that's why like I get the idea of going
to the employee um but you are you're
you're dealing out benefits that
traditionally come from employers and
you're dealing with people who may not
understand the tax implications of
getting of getting PTO um and not
understanding like I'm self-employed so
I know that when somebody hands me a
check for $100 I have to put $25 aside
and I get to spend $75 like I know that
because I have to pay the IRS every year
um childcare employees are not used to
that they come to me in January 31
where's my W2 I want my refund um that's
not you're not setting that system up
you're setting them up for actually kind
of a system uh where they may be in in
some trouble um uh kind of just a
administratively by the way can we throw
G like we throw J into F like tele
medicine is mostly covered by Insurance
anyways so just like can we just toss
that oh yeah if I may there actually is
an option to do and a lot of childcare
um employees are doing it now that they
many of them have health insurance but
they have very high deductibles and a
lot of them do not have teleah health
and if they do it's not 247 there are
some options out there that are very
affordable for tella Health that New
Hampshire folks are using now and it'd
be great if they could be
supported I'm not talking about getting
rid of it I'm just talking about I'm
just talking about for the purpose of
concisus you're dealing with health
benefits put l why not just put the why
not put the other health benefit in the
line with the health benefit that's just
purely I'm not talking about getting rid
of it I'm talking about administratively
just St it up there um yeah just yeah
like less is trust me cuz Finance is
going to have a field day with it too um
you know Sor go ahead yeses yes thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
listening um I've I've applied for
Grants there's criteria that shall be
met when you apply for a grant these
receipts can be part of that criteria so
if we have an employee
who is eligible and the employer is
going going to apply the employer gives
the employee this incentive to say bring
me your receipts I'm applying for a
grant I believe you should benefit from
that Grant bring me your receipt so it
can be included in the Grant
application and it helps the
employer because there are hopefully
many employees who are going to to be
eligible right so it helps the employer
with his or her grant
writing to include that so that's why I
think it's
actually I I agree that it should be the
employer and as far as the receipts are
concerned that can be handled in that
manner yeah and and remember like the
whole point of this is retention right
so you know if you're if you're filing
for expenses after the fact right well
you know that the expenses you know that
the benefit was dled out right you know
it was given right and the whole point
is to give it to retention um and you
know like giving things for in the
future always concerns me because it's
like you don't know what's going to
happen like once they have the money you
don't know what's going to happen um but
like you know I I always and I've said
this before I always look at things to
the lens of um you know my own center
right so like we just did our entire
Center just did our reup on CPR I paid
for it we stayed after they all got uh
they all got time and a half because we
were on OT right I just ate that as the
employer right um because my teachers
have to have CPR like it's just one of
the deals so you know it's you're
dealing with things
that um I I I really am Adam about this
you're dealing with the exception of the
student loan repayment which I am
totally cool to move to the CTE yeah the
CTE continuing education um you know cuz
you're talking about like Pro Solutions
and stuff like that um I'm totally cool
to go there I think that's actually way
more agreeable um but I I really am like
I am stuck on it it needs to flow
through the employer it needs to be for
appr proven costs because the the idea
is is if you tell the employer hey we're
going to start um the States you know
you tell them you know all right we've
gotten this much money in the pot you
know you're going to get this much to do
over these benefits prove that you're
doing it um now the employer is going to
be able to offer these benefits right
they're not going to not do it I mean
why would anybody why would any
employer not give I'm using air quotes
here cuz I don't believe I
philosophically I have trouble saying
this free um benefits um why would any
employer not do that it would be
ludicrous not to do that um it would be
you would be run out of business your
your competition alone would put you
under the ground
um if it's coming from the state the
state has never not paid me I'll say
that the state has never
not yeah and like
yeah yeah uh go ahead yes thank you
chair Barry um I just wanted to mention
you know in hearing this we're all
sitting here because we're acknowledging
that there's a child care crisis and
what it makes me think back to is during
covid and I know um chair Barry you're a
small business owner I am as well and
this is a bit of a political landmine
but what happened when covid shut us all
down as small business owners is we
recognized we need to get money in the
hands of these businesses right away
with you know removing some of these
rails and so what it makes me think of
is to address these issues we have the
the quickest way to get the the extra
sort of funds to our our Workforce but
what if we looked at it where we said
there's a there's an annual audit that
takes place and people get pulled
randomly to be ensured that it's you
know being spent the way that we wanted
to be spent a random I I still don't
like it being a random audit of the
employee um because it's just it's just
not I just I I know it's just not going
to end well it's just I'm just telling
you it is not going to end well um the
employer has accounting mechanisms
already in place right the teacher does
not have the teacher likely does not
have the same account like the teacher
doesn't have a QuickBooks account right
every every dollarin and every dollar
out of my Center goes through a
QuickBooks account right you ask me how
much profit I made last month I can tell
you in 10 seconds um because I have to
account for every dollar because I have
to give it to the IRS I have to give it
to our friends at Dr right um you're
you're involving people you're giving
money to people who directly you I I
actually think you will be causing them
more harm by giving it to them directly
than just allowing the benefit to flow
through the employer which it every
single one of these is e everything that
like I'll go back to my own Center I pay
the $28 fee for background check if you
come and you work for my center and you
don't have your background check I give
I give you $28 check to the Department
of Safety you go on down to Haz and
drive like I do that right um so you
could actually see like centers like
mine you might see cost shifting right I
might say ah you know I don't need to
pay your $28 you can reimburse yourself
with the
state right you might see cost shifting
so it is I'm telling you it is a much
better system to just run it through the
employer run it through DHHS um and not
try to do a direct Dole a direct payment
to a person a a person who doesn't you
know doesn't understand account like I'm
not trying I I love our teachers they're
some of the best people in the world
right they're not accountants right um
they didn't that's not they didn't raise
their hand to be accountants they raise
their hand to be teachers God bless them
I can't do it I was in a classroom two
days ago and six hours in I was like oh
my god um but you know I like handling
money like I I'm that I'm good at um
you're you're asking you're you're going
to give them something that I don't
there's a way to give them the benefit
that doesn't involve them assuming the
liability
that's what I'm saying like all
right yes so R Barry just to to respond
to what you said and and um I certainly
understand where you're coming from but
again thinking back during covid I'm a
lawyer and not an accountant U there's a
reason I have a bookkeeper but I know
when my business needed those funds
there were very clear categories you
could spend those funds on and this is a
to me this is a pretty small pool of
different categories and um you know it
just wasn't very difficult to keep a
fold and a record of here's how I here's
how I spend my funds so um I'm not sure
that I fully disagree that it would be
too difficult on the
employees I I I hear that uh I would
also point out you have a
JD right um You are a highly educated
person right um You are not you do not
need a JD to be a teacher um I'm not
saying you're bad I'm not saying it's
bad don't get me wrong we have plenty of
bachelor's teachers I'm you're you're
misinterpreting what I'm saying I'm
saying you are putting them into a
situation where you might be set setting
them up for failure we can get them the
benefits that they want we can get them
the benefits that I think they need we
can do that without creating tax
liabilities for them right the PTO
benefit alone is a tax liability the
employer pays 7% of every of every
paycheck you get your employer is
responsible you have 14% payroll tax
your employer is charge of 7% how does
that work if the money doesn't flow
through the employer how does it work
the answer is it doesn't it doesn't work
because they're at that point are they
considered self-employed all right so
now their tax liability goes from 14% in
which the employer is paying 7 to 25% so
you're going to hand them money for PTO
do you think they're going to know do
have the where are they going to have
the tax training to know they need to
take 25% put it in their pocket and put
into savings account because they're
going to owe it are they going to start
owing coure release right or they just
going to owe on April 15th these are all
things that you're setting up you're not
setting this program up for Success
you're you're setting you are setting it
up I believe you're setting people up
for failure um and it's it's going like
it's not from the heartless I'm not here
I'm not up here saying don't do this
right I'm not saying here don't do this
benefit you're not hearing those words
come out of my mouth what I'm saying is
don't do it directly to the employee
because you're going to set up things
that are not you're going to set them up
into a system that is not that they're
not may not be ready to do you know
these are people who file W2s right they
don't I have to I have to when I do mine
I have to file 10 I have to send out
1099s I have to take in 1099s right I
have this whole it takes me basically a
month to do my taxes right they are you
are effectively making them small
businesses when you do this so now like
these you're setting this this situation
up it is just so much simpler to just
run it through the employer employer who
already has a Rel every employer in
share CS that I know has a relationship
with DHHS they know the grant they know
the grant fund they get the the survey
monkey thing right um You they're
already equipped to do that you are now
shifting that onto a whole group of
people I could actually make the
argument that some of them may not take
advantage of it because it may be
confusing it's just way easier if it
flows to the employer and I actually
think you'll get more good to more
teachers that way than if you would if
you just tried to say hey you can apply
for this um you know good luck cuz you
know you have all sorts of other
questions right like how are you going
to know notify these teachers that this
is available if their employer doesn't
tell them right how are they even going
to know about it because are you going
to send out certified mail to every
person who has a current background
check with DHHS you could do that right
but if you just but you send out to the
350 some odd childcare providers in the
state of New Hampshire hey this
program's coming on board uh by July 1st
this fund's going to be established this
is what we're trying to do by the way
give us some feedback how do you think
it'll work right it's a way better
process to deal with that pool of people
than the than every every teacher in the
state of New Hampshire you see what I'm
saying it's not about not giving them
the benefit it's about how do we get the
benefit to them effectively without
setting them up for
failure thank you Mr chairman in another
life I was that mean horrible IRS
auditor I really really wasn't mean and
I really wasn't horrible however
if you have ever
seen the condition of the
receipts during an
audit
it it's
shocking most PE W2 filers
don't understand the necessity to hold
on to receipts what receipts they should
hold on to what receipts they they don't
need to coffee stains peanut butter
stains and
all it is so much better and more
efficient for an
employer to be the one to hold all that
information considering the fact that if
you are an
employer you have a
bookkeeping
Department there's where all the
receipts are held it is in one place
instead of some auditor walking into a
W2 Filer and saying H not IRS but DHHS
or whomever is going to be the auditor
and saying I want your receipts they're
going to be uh uh uh the baby formula
spilled all over it so I threw it
out it works better it's more efficient
it's more streamlined and that's why I
like the
employer as opposed to the
employee can I share something uh sure
let me let me give an anecdotal story
before we do that um so I have I just
recently gave um I just recently gave
one of my employees a promotion uh
brought her up to assistant director and
my game plan is to make her the director
so I can go off start another child care
center um she got a rais with that
obviously more responsibilities more
money right she had a tax liability
after she filed she came to me said Ross
uh the IRS says I owe him $0000 what am
I going to do and she's like well first
first thing she said is did you do my
taxes right I said that is all automated
like I don't you know what goes in like
you fill out your thing online I don't
do math like QuickBooks does the math
but we I actually sat down with her and
went over it and yeah like she because
of the raise she owed a tax
liability she's not going to be able to
make April 15th I know that um I had to
go over with I I told like hey I've been
here trust me um like you know what
you're going to do is you're going to
file on the you're going to file for uh
you're file on the 15th you're going to
send them saying you know you this money
you're going to set up a payment plan
they're going to charge you 18% interest
rate by the way financially you need to
get that paid off as quickly as possible
because 18% is gross
um imag so I imagine that conver the
reason I'm so passionate about this is I
imagine having that
conversation with every one of my
teachers who takes PTO and then gets
some form of W2 or something or 1099
from the state of New Hampshire and then
they go and they plug it in and then
they're like oh I owe two grand to the
IRS in April that is going to happen
like if that benefit that PTO benefit
which nobody have I've I've heard nobody
say take it out so if that PTO benefit
sticks in there and it's applicable
there's tax liability with
that that conver that that horrible
conversation I had to have with by the
way single mother just so you know
single mother uh that horrible
conversation I had to have with her
about how how she was going to get
through this and basically be her
financial adviser which is not a job I
signed up for but happy to
help that's going to happen across the
state of New Hampshire if you give
benefits directly to employees that's
going to happen again and again and
again and then we're going to be back
here in 2 years having some conversation
about how we fix that problem so let's
just not have that problem that's my
point anys represent of Pat thank you
can
um
so if we do this through the
employer one of the things I'm trying to
Grapple with here is how we ensure that
it's predictable for the provider
um and what I'm hearing is sort of a pay
as you go from whoever's administering
like the receipts come in and then they
get they get be they get
reimbursed I'm I'm hearing you about why
you think it makes sense for it to FL
flow through through the
provider my concern is I'm hearing a lot
directly from providers about how
they're already feeling stress around
being able to access funding that has
been promised and feeling yanked around
um so I'm I'm trying to understand in in
this model that you're
envisioning when do they get the money
you know could we at least you know
provide it upfront to the to the
provider and then draw it down because
what my fear is sort of there's there's
so much
ageta
around being able to plan you know to be
able to understand that the that the
employees will get these benefits so I
I'm I'm keeping an open mind on how we
best administer this and how the funds
flow but I want to make sure that the
provider is able to say you know with
confidence to their employee your
tuition assistance is covered or what
whatever the decision may be right so I
I'm I'm keeping an open mind but I just
want to put that out there as a worry
that I have as we're moving in that
direction yeah I totally agree with that
I mean represent like what do you do how
do you distribute this money right
because you don't want to get to
September and it runs out of cash right
um which is why I said kind of at the
beginning like if I was if I was the
financial God of this program I would
take the amount of money that was given
I would divid up by you know current
enrollment on X date probably for me
would be Jan one right and I would say
you have as the employer you you know
employer of you know you know Little
Learners has access to you know 15500
you know $15,000 to provide employee
benefits across the following benefit
allocations right um and as an employer
you know that that fund is available um
and then we just have to deal with what
happens with unexpended funds at the end
of the year but knowing employee
employers as I do um my guess is that
fund would be damn near zero U if you if
you knew that they could go and pull x
amount of dollars and they knew that
number uh very early on in the um very
early on in in the uh fiscal calendar
year I just um I I'm Maran ber from the
childcare advisory Council and we've
done a lot of research on this um Maine
right now does direct bonuses to the
staff people to the teachers and it has
helped with retention it's it goes
through their DHHS it's a quarterly
bonus Sy or a monthly bonus system I'm
sorry and it's just checks that go out
without any attachment of how that has
to be spent they assume they're spending
it for housing or they food or whatever
so I understand that's not exactly the
New Hampshire way of doing it but the
childcare advisory council is truly
worried about child care Without Borders
right so if you leave me if I run a
childcare facility in conquered if you
leave my child care facility I want you
to stay in the field and go to your
child care facility or Lynn's child care
facility and what happens with the DHHS
grants say we just do not have the level
of participation that we would like to
see primarily because it does does go
through these really really overstressed
directors and owners of the business the
core Grant has been sort of a disaster
and um because there were a lot of guard
rails around it they it required
insurance levels that U family child
care providers do not have so they were
not able to benefit from it and
documentation without knowing the amount
that you're going to get back so we have
people who've been turning in 300 pages
of documentation of expenses and they
don't know whether they're going to get
back $50 or 50,000
and so that is a real Challenge and a
huge paperwork burden I've we've also
heard from um business owners that they
do not want any sort of financial burden
of this they don't want to have to count
these funds as income and if they do
count them as income there has to be
some sort of mechanism where they can
save out some to cover their expenses
and how we best work that so I agree
with you that um it's a tremendous
burden to ask people to understand their
taxes and it's frustrating and it might
really hurt people um but it seems to be
the systems that worked best across the
country but it's but if it's not the New
Hampshire way that's fine I just want to
ensure that people stay in the field
regardless of what business they are at
and regardless of whether they move to
another town please don't go to work at
Dunkin Donuts please stay in child care
and open up a child care facility in
that town Fran thank you um I was just
wondering do you know for
Maine is it too simplistic to say can we
write something in the bill to say this
money would be taxfree so you don't have
to worry about it you know no they they
have a tax problem they have a tax
problem or or taking it out okay yeah um
and it is a problem representative
Barry's right it's a problem and the
first year that they did it it's not a
problem for everybody because most
childcare providers are really broke I
mean it's not we're not talking a lot of
ton of money here but for married
providers it was an issue and so I think
that we acknowledge there's going to
have to be an education piece that's
pretty extraordinary that goes with us
and regardless of whether it goes
through the employer or goes through the
um goes straight to the teacher
themselves there's going to have to be
an educational piece to this because
right now and Jesse probably knows this
a little bit better than I do but um I
believe the most amount of people we've
had apply for a grant in grant funding
in the state is around 450 I don't think
we've broken 500 yet and we have 750
provid licensed providers in the state
so what's going on what's going on with
this 250 that they're not applying for
funds some of it might be philosophical
some of them might be very wealthy and
they don't need to I would find that
surprising but I would worry an awful
lot about those staff not being able to
access what's going to keep them in the
field yes so I hear all that but it's
you know if you have a we not I don't
believe use as a grant right um you're
effectively setting up a revolving fund
that once I know how politics Works once
money is allocated into that thing the
likelihood that it's ever going to go
down is very low um because who's going
to be the politician that's going to
raise their hand and say yep I'm
draining the child care fund um so I I
live in that reality of I know how
politics Works um once the money goes
into that you can make the argument it
would never go up that's definitely
possible um but you can never make the
argument to me that it would go down um
the having it be a set a set amount per
employer from the beginning and DHHS can
send out hey we've calculated this up uh
we believe you're eligible for X all
right and if it's worth the employer's
time which if it's you know a $20
million fund it definitely will be um I
can promise you they're going to apply
the the issue is the the current you
know everybody wants to reference the
current Grant applications I have filled
out the current Grant applications so I
know about them right they are insane
right it's all like all right I've got
this teacher in this room making this
much money uh with this ratio um it's
nuts like it takes a long time that's
I'll tell you right now I haven't talked
to as many chocolate as you have that's
why you don't have 200 people filling
out because you load the thing up and
it's insane that being said I don't
think this is like that we're not asking
them to
produce why would we be asking them to
produce ratios in rooms at times of days
and stuff like that why why would we
asking that it's like hey uh show me
what you sent to Harvard
Pilgrim okay cool click here you go
right um I think we're way over
complicating I think we're taking the
the two existing grants that are out
there which are admittedly I haven't
even filled out the second one yet
because I keep loading it up and going
oh my god um I think it's due the 23rd
right I've got some
um see I know I know that's how you know
I'm looking at um I don't make this
stuff up I swear I live in this world um
but we're not I don't think I don't
think we're talking about that I don't
see why DHHS would be interested in that
um it's not the benefit that we're
looking to provide um arguably the one
thing you'd have to provide is a copy of
your
payroll okay I could pull that off my
phone right now um I I think it's I
think we're taking our experiences with
the current Grant application that's
closed and the current one that's open
till the 23rd we're applying that to
something that doesn't yet exist and
what I'm telling you is they don't have
to be like that it doesn't you don't
have to live in that world you can live
in a world in which an employer files
for reimbursement um there's plenty of
software out there by the way uh I I do
imagine DHHS would need a staffer for
this somebody to sit there God bless
that person all day is going to be
looking at receipts but
um there somebody will do it I promise
you um I don't I I think we're making it
I think in the attempt to get the money
directly there right and setting up
problems for the providers I think we're
overlooking what is the obvious Avenue
that I think will actually deliver the
most good I I think more employers will
take advantage of it than providers I
could see providers getting to the end
of the year and be like I forgot to file
H
whatever I can see I can see that
happening like dealing with them every
day I could see that happening I don't
want that to happen to them I want them
to have the benefits right I want them
to get this stuff I want the employers
to provide better Ben benefits because
they know at the beginning of the year
they're going to have this financial
stability from the state and that they
can then feel comfortable providing
those benefits that's going to lift the
industry up as a whole right not just
you know saying all right like you know
we're going to set this thing up and
have this Mass education system for you
know how many child provide how many
childcare teachers are there in the
state of New Hampshire right there
thousands right thousand 5,500 so you're
talking about educating 5,500 people or
educating 700 business owners what do
you think is going to be the more uous
task right who do you think's more
likely to participate like let's just be
real right I I I love these teachers I
really do like I I i' really do love
them I want what's best for them I want
to get them what's best for them I don't
believe going directly to them is
actually the best way to do it it's use
the system that already exists use the
department I sounds like we're good on
the department but use the department
that the is already handling the
childcare centers to begin with um and
it just it all it all makes sense any so
I'm going to stop beating this today
death um that those are my thoughts on
it I'd like to hear from the other side
of the aisle on it if we can come to
consensus then we can file this thing
off to OS and maybe vote on it this
afternoon so um I was wondering as you
were talking I was wondering if there
was some way of writing this so that we
make it tighten it up so that this is a
pass through directly to the
employees directly to the teachers
through the employer if that's the
preference but it has to go there has to
be directly to the teachers um and
without without all the receipts and
everything from the teachers but it goes
directly as a bonus program directly as
a bonus program um to the teachers and
they can use it however they deem if
they have to use it on housing or
groceries or whatever it is well at that
point you're just talking about
supplemental pay right yes um that's
that's what you you just that's what
they need um the point right let's get
to the
point yeah I don't I I mean now
we're it makes so the benefit side of it
if you if you give them pay right now
the employers incurred a tax liability
but to be fair their employees getting a
benefit um so you're asking the
employers to eat a little bit of that I
imagine they would claw back somewhere
else um benefits are you can write as
the employer you can write them off
right
um so like my I already give my
employees PTO it it means nothing to me
that that like the state coming in doing
that wouldn't do anything for me I
already give it to them um but you know
it would be great for me to be able to
lower their healthare costs because
right now I can only cover about $50 a
week per employee of their side of the
premium um like it'd be nice for me I
think more I think more of my employees
would take advantage of it um because I
do offer a very
nice healthcare plan I I I'll give an
example my child spent 8 days in the niq
we had 116,000 Bill we were on the same
plan as our employers the total
liability for for me was
$234 why because I employ a lot of women
under the age of 30 so when I set up
that insurance you can imagine I moved
maternity and nursing care all the way
up because a lot of my teachers they are
of that age they get pregnant they have
children I want I wanted that service
available to them I wasn't aware that my
wife would be the first one to take
advantage of it um but you know that's
that's how most employers would view
this if you give them that opportunity I
believe they'll do the right thing
um I think just handing down the money
might be too big of a pill to swallow
for my side um you're already asking us
to kind of move off of like because the
default answer from the Republican side
of this would just be no we're
establishing a program to give out money
the default answer is no we're trying to
work in good faith on that and I think
that might be a bridge too far for us so
that's what I'm trying to get
to okay so are we going to be able to
reach any consensus on this like like
where are we at you kind of know I think
I've I've beaten this microphone to
death um trying to make this work so
like where are we at what can we agree
to M Williams this is your bill let's
start off uh thank you chair Barry um it
seems like there are some points that we
can definitely work together on this
bill um and I think that in the
interests of getting the fund set up I
think it's okay to put something on
paper to get the fund set up and if we
have to do future legislation in a year
or two or three like we do on so many
other things
we may have to do that but I think the
priority here is making sure that we can
at least create the fund um with the
intent that we are benefiting Child Care
employees for Recruitment and Retention
because that's the need right now um and
I think that need will continue um
because of the economics of child care
in New Hampshire and around the the
United States um so setting up the fund
I think is the priority um that being
said I think a lot of the things that
we've discussed are um are pretty easy
to put in as an Amendment uh but I what
I'd like to do is do a committee wide
Amendment if we can come to a consensus
that's what I'm talk yeah I I don't want
to just do a McWilliams Amendment on
this obviously I don't think it's going
to go anywhere and the MC Williams
Amendment would look different than the
committee Amendment so we just be clear
uh but I think that that there's a
there's a way for us to find um a middle
ground to get this rolling and
understanding that this needs to go to
finance next so they will iron out some
of those um nuanced questions that I
don't think this committee should be
spending time on in terms of like uh you
talked about the uh enrollment
proportionality I I think that's
probably a finance discussion not an us
discussion which is okay uh but so in
the interest of of at least you know if
if we need to go through employers
because they're only 700ish employers
rather than employees because there are
5,500 okay let's set it up that way um I
do want to be very cautious about that
because as you mentioned there's a
certain percentage of businesses that
just don't apply for Grants so that
could leave those employees high and dry
because they're they know they're
eligible for their health insurance to
get covered and they may even submit
that to the employer and then the
employer sits on it so there's an
unfairness piece that maybe needs a
little bit of a I don't know a way to
work with that but okay and maybe the
unfairness is those employees end up
leaving those employers but with child
care but with child care it's so
geographically based you know if this is
a Coos employer and there's only two of
them then it's not like those employees
can just uproot and go elsewhere so
they'd like to walk with their feet they
probably will leave the industry rather
than forcing their employer or going
around the employer to apply for the
grant themselves but In fairness and I'm
a middle child so fairness is very
important so In fairness I think that we
want to have some kind of a back door to
allow employees whose employers don't
apply to at least try because if you're
stuck geographically you're really stuck
and that's not fair yeah actually I I
think I can agree to that if the
employer doesn't apply I think I can
agree to that because that that the free
market side of me says they would move
but you are right in Coos County there's
probably like three providers uh and
that may not be an option for them um so
I I'm willing to I'm willing to to meet
you on that okay all right I I think we
can make this work I think that we have
enough common ground that we can set up
this fund and um certainly finance will
have more edits to this so we can submit
what we've got in terms of the Common
Ground um I I'm open to any other
discussion on
this um so we're good on striking
student loan payment and putting that
into C changing that to CTE or
continuing education costs sorry job
related education
exp
uh oh yeah well it is yeah then Dam we
could just get rid of it then job
related education expenses so we have so
we have the CTE that we want and we
won't do the student loan repayment it's
just not going to happen are we cool
putting the T medicine coverage up into
F I know that that's that that's like
purely just like put it right where that
belongs um and then I assume we're good
with DHHS yep right uh and we're good
with
striking uh uh Part B of section 4 for
preference which I guess we're going to
have to figure out how to do that with
the um people actually it does you
know
oh yes that's very important yes we need
to put rules in there um I have that
underline right on the top of it
rules DHHS will promate rules um and
then um okay y all right so uh mck uh
repres MC Williams you want to submit
that Amendment put my put me on it with
you um if we're lucky we'll get we'll
get it back from OS
today can I how many can I put on it can
I put the whole committee on it yeah you
if if if they're agreable to it let's
put everyone on it I agree yeah let's
put everyone on it all right is
everybody is everybody everybody good
with that
okay okay all right all right so with
that we're going to end the snap
executive session and go back to public
hearings and we're only oh God an hour
and a half behind but hey you know all
right all right moving on uh we're going
to open up the public hearing on House
Bill 1056 relative to the administration
of the scholarship program which I
believe representative D Simone you are
the sponsor of
um yeah just go ahead and introduce it
it's pretty simple bill um so you guys
know uh represented D Simon and I work
together on a lot of these bills um but
we put her as the lead because if she
test if I was the if I am the chair and
I get up and I I advocate for the bill
eye then it can no longer participate in
the hearing um so there I told her I
would take the ones that were a little
spicier um and I would give her the ones
that I thought were probably more
consensus driven so all right thank you
thank you represent DY for being here
it's great thank you Mr chairman and
thank you committee for allowing me to
speak for the record I'm representative
Deb D Simone I represent Rockingham 18
which is Atkinson New Hampshire one of
the most southern
communities
um my family will not believe that there
is somebody who talks more than me
representative
Barry
um representative Barry and I worked on
this bill um concerning the child care
scholarship program administered by the
department um and we want them to
prioritize the applications of the uh
Child Care
employees um it's pretty
self-explanatory it's easy peasy um I'm
sure representative Barry will want to
add to anything that I say so I'll leave
the rest up to representative Barry if
he so chooses so chooses any
questions I don't have any questions
does any have any questions okay um
there's only one other person signed up
to speak uh Jesse Davis from DHHS thank
you we might even get some time back who
knows it's we definitely ain't making
lunch that's for sh hello I'm Jesse
Davis I'm the bureau chief um of Child
Development and Head Start collaboration
for the department and um I just want to
caution the committee that this would
put us in out of compliance with Federal
Regulation we cannot discriminate
against a certain type of family for
eligibility for the scholarship
fund okay questions from the committee
represent MC Williams do you have a
recommendation for how we could get
around that
I unfortunately did not come come
prepared for a recommendation of a
workaround um I do know that also um
there is no waiting period you can
reapply at any time
so cool um do you believe we passes the
that's my favorite question to always
ask because the feds like to give money
and then put a bunch of strings on it
and I like to call their Bluff do you
believe they would actually take away
our child care scholarship if we
prioritize the applications of childcare
workers
I know that they could I know the answer
is they could my question is is would
they we would have Federal findings for
this yes and we would have to have
correction corrective action plan and we
would have to yes it would it yes it
would put us at
risk
represent um is there any kind of
prioritization that currently happens
like first come first served or how are
they prioritized currently it is based
on the amount of funds that we have
available and who is applying so yes you
would get to a waiting period if you
have more families who are eligible so
the answer to that would be yes first
come first serve okay further questions
from the committee all right seeing none
thank you has anyone else signed up to
speak can you represent MC Williams can
you toss me the blue
sheet uh
1056 NOP yes yep I can't
read uh why is this bill
not huh it's not listed online that's
strange all right well no
online okay uh signed up and not
speaking there were two in favor so with
that we get some time back we'll close
the Committee hearing on House Bill
1056 and open up the uh public hearing
on House Bill 10 uh
1405 uh I think we can
manage for the rest um actually actually
tell you what uh represent Deon let me
introduce this bill you take the chair
because this one's kind of NE Niche
um I'll leave a pink card for your
represent
[Music]
not okay um so uh my name is
representative Ros Berry I represent
Hillsboro oh goodness oh goodness can I
be recognized I can I recognize myself
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam chair um my name is
representative Ros Berry I represent
Hillsboro 39 Manchester WS 689 the fight
in the South End um here to introduce
House Bill 1405 relative to limiting the
publication of chalk care violations so
this comes uh at the request of our
friend Kora from Rochester uh she
testified about this about how her
insurance rates doubled um due to the
publications of findings that were not
in her I wish she was here um but to her
to her statement uh were not material to
the safety or well-being of a child um
the basically the insurance company this
is what she says the insurance company
went in pulled her file um she has what
she says was paperwork violations um and
they Ed that as the impetus to double
her insurance bill um so I told her when
I was talking to her outside of our
listening session uh in Conway um that
uh I would do something about it and
this is what I did um so I'm sure it
will need to be worked on I'm sure ghhs
will have um some things to say about it
and some things about why we can or
cannot do certain things um but I want
everyone to know this this comes
directly from our public hearings this
comes directly from one of our providers
um it is a problem that I looked at and
I said there's a way to do this we don't
want to not publish the findings of
safety violations right so if you're not
being safe right not covering that up
insurance companies by the way have a
right to know that um if we're dinging
somebody because they don't have
paperwork right and then their costs for
insurance are doubling which is what are
claiming um that's a problem I believe
the state can solve um so with that um
I'm sure the I'm sure the bill will need
tons of work but I'm interested to hear
people say and I'm actually going to go
and get a glass of water so I'll see
what's up and I'll fill out the pink
card do we have any more pink cards on
this
one5 we
do thank you m representative Barry um
the next two people we have that would
like three minutes to speak are Melissa
Clement and Jesse
Davis you're welcome to come up bring
there's a rolling chair there if you
want to bring it
over
um thank you for coming forward the
floor is yours thank you madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Melissa Clement and I am the chief of
the childcare life sensing unit for the
Department of DHHS I'm Jesse Davis
bureau chief of Child Development and
Head Start
collaboration um so we fully understand
the concerns of the providers regarding
this bill it's come to our attention
that insurance companies are using
findings that are made by the department
in order to either drop insurance or
change insurance and while we we
completely understand that at the same
time we have a responsibility to when we
monitor programs on their that we have
to post these online and in addition to
what we Post online the um Jesse will
speak more to the requirements under the
child care Development Fund regarding
that it cannot be a summary it has to
show what we saw during the inspection
what was in compliance and what was not
in compliance so we have shifted our
system so that we're not only showing
what the citations were but we're also
showing what they were in compliance
because that is a federal requirement if
we move forward with something like this
it would require changes to the systems
that we have in place um we put together
a fiscal note worksheet that you should
have received I believe you have it and
based on previous assessments we
couldn't get a quote specifically for
this one item but when we've made system
changes in the past for similar
situations it could cost as low as
$78,000 or as much as $500,000 depending
on the amount of um changes that we have
to make in our system in addition to
that um the impact would be to the child
care Development Fund and I'll let Jesse
speak yeah so there is a federal
requirement that we must post both
compliance and non-compliance for all
monitoring visits and so for all Child
Care scholarship eligible programs this
would put them out of compliance and
again put the state out of
compliance thank you for your testimon
will you take questions absolutely thank
you Williams thank you representative
thank you so much chair um similar
question do you have recommendations for
how this could be
resolved I um I come to New Hampshire
new um and I come from the state of
Idaho and in the state of Idaho they do
allow programs to correct those findings
and then they republish those findings
that could potentially be a way to
support the Child Care community and
that they've corrected the violation and
our current as Jesse mentioned being new
so our current process here is we find a
citation the program um writes a
corrective action plan and then the
department accepts that corrective
action plan and ensures you know the
items were corrected and then they're
posted
online so that's the process we have
currently and then we go out and monitor
again so the insurance companies can see
that there's a three-year history of
what the program has had for citations
for the last three
years thank you for your question
representative wner yes could you just
talk a minute I thought I heard you say
you do both things that are
non-compliant and compliant so I mean I
would assume that almost all of the
reports would be extremely long with all
everything that's in compliance so how
do you how do you do how do you um show
that on the sure so I can certainly send
the committee a link to our most recent
the current system that we're using and
you'll see that we've grouped like items
together so there's certain what is
called domains such as one will be
records one will be care of children one
is medication so in each of those
domains it's like a drop down so there's
a little icon that shows what in
compliance and what's not in compliance
and there's a number so it shows the
number of items that were reviewed at
the visit and then the number of items
that were in compliance as like a quick
view and then we also post our what you
would normally see as a statement of
findings which just shows the citations
and their corrective action plan but
it's all together now it looks
completely different than what you've
probably seen in the
past I would could I have a followup I
just wondered when did you start using
that system um it was last summer so Ju
July of 2023 was when we
first thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
time
I'm sorry can we please have the blue
sheet on um
absolutely thank you very much and I'm
sorry um I forgot to mention this thank
you Dorene manager for reminding me um
when we became aware of this issue with
the um the insurance companies
cancelling and changing it we did reach
out to the commissioner of the insurance
department and he did join a meeting at
I don't know if childcare advisory
Council or early learning New Hampshire
one of those so that he could speak
directly so that we can hopefully go
from that angle and make sure that the
insurance dep department has a better
understanding of our process and what we
do so that this doesn't continue to
occur so we're also working it from that
angle as well and thank you for allowing
me to come back sure thank you for the
information you have a
question thank you chair um do you think
that this is something that can be
resolved just with conversations or do
you think it's something that maybe we
would need to pursue from you know
telling insurance companies sorry you
can't change um I mean that's what
that's a conversation that we're having
with the commissioner over at the
insurance department is to determine
what other avenues that we can take for
this so that it doesn't impact child
care providers it's um childcare
providers child daycare and also child
residential providers all these
providers are being hit with insurance
costs that are skyrocketing or being
cancelled so it's across the
board anything
further seeing no one thank you very
much thank you very much for give me
that additional
time I do see on the blue sheet three
people signed up some of them did
testify um they on the blue sheet they
did not disclose whether they were Pro
or
con with that I'll close the uh hearing
on uh
1405 and take a twom minute recess to
see if our esteem chair comes
back
okay all right uh sorry about that y'all
just kind of hanging outside drinking a
diet coke
um the uh okay uh so we just did that
one bill
um uh no let me take the slings and
arrows on this one um because this is
going to be the one that's going to be
the contentious one uh I'll fill out a
card for you here's that
one I'll wait for you to recognize me
Madam
Sher follow the rules
I'm a rule
follower okay I will now open the
hearing on House Bill
1407 I will recognize representative
Barry from Hillsboro
39 y thank you representative bar
welcome thank you madam chairman um my
name is representative Ross Barry I
represent Hillsboro 39 Manchester 689
the fighting South End um it's for all
my Manchester people um so uh what we
have here 1407 is modifies the child
care uh the teacher to staff ratios so I
know this is going to be outside of
maybe the bill we did earlier this
morning this might be the other super
contentious thing that we have a
discussion on um in
my we all acknowledge we're in a crisis
I we don't need to go over that there is
one thing that the state can do
literally today that would increase
access and affordability and that is to
allow more children in the classroom the
question for the committee the question
for the state is what detriment is that
to quality and safety right so instead
of doing a wholesale increase right so
instead of taking one to four and moving
it to 1 to five I try to preemptively
find a middle ground that wouldn't cause
people to overreact and have an actual
actual honest conversation about this so
let's talk about infant care since
that's actually where the biggest crunch
is right the reason infant care by the
way has the biggest crunch in the state
is it has the however you want to look
at it highest or lowest ratio um it's
technically the highest but um
mathematically it's the highest but we
would prefer just the lowest uh the
lowest ratio of a four four infants four
children on the age of one to one
teacher in the
classroom no child care center can make
a profit off of that that is entirely a
break even um Venture the only way to
make a profit off the average infant
care I think it's north of $300 a week
at this point um you're talking about
$155,000 a year per infant right it is
the most expensive part of the child
care
cycle so I've been in the infant room um
it's the toughest definitely by the way
I think it's the toughest room they say
the two-year-olds the toughest but I
actually think the infants are the
toughest because they they're either all
asleep or they're all needy at once um
and when they when the infant needs
attention the infant needs attention um
so the the issue is is I didn't take it
from 1 to five I didn't I'm not saying
we're going to just increase it 20% on
one teacher that's a lot uh five infants
to one teacher is a lot some by the way
some states do that um I don't know if
it's appropriate for New Hampshire to do
that so what I said was if there's a
second teacher in the room instead of
having a 2 to8 ratio you can go to 2 to9
right so instead of a 20% a 20 a 25%
increase we're talking about a 122%
increase um the things I don't like
about this um I don't like that it's not
going to apply to every Childcare Center
right if your room is not licensed to
hold over over eight right it doesn't
matter that your ratio is 2 to n now um
if the fire code says you can't have
more than eight in that room it doesn't
matter that your ratio says 2 to n now
um but the question and I hope the
committee and I hope those in in
presence will have an honest
conversation about is we talk about the
ways to provide increased access
increased affordability and the answer
is always the same you know from people
it's like let's throw more money at the
problem and see if it goes away and we
just had a long conversation about that
obviously I'm open to that conversation
in my heart of hearts I don't believe it
solves the long-term problems the way to
create relief today is to take the
existing spaces that we have where we
can safely do it and expand it today
that's the way to fix it today right
that doesn't mean by the way the problem
goes away it's a relief
valve but it's something that we need to
have an open and honest conversation
about and it's it's something that I
hope that we don't just the cackles go
up and we say no um in case you're
wondering where I got this idea from I
actually got the idea from Massachusetts
um Massachusetts to their credit they
start with a lower ratio to begin with
so they start at 1 to three um and then
when they get that second child they go
to basically two to seven um so the idea
came from them we started up higher them
to begin with um but I I knew that just
adding one to everyone would pretty much
be a non-starter quite honestly I don't
even know if it would be practical I
don't even know if as a business owner I
would put U even if I could I don't
think I would put five infants on one
teacher I don't actually don't think I
would do that to my staff um but a lot
of the centers already do what's called
over enrolling right so if their room's
licensed to eight they'll enroll to nine
basically crossing their fingers that
one um one kid won't show up that day
day it's a very common practice they'll
bump a kid up they'll bump a kid down
right they'll make it work uh it's hard
on infants because you can't bump them
down right there's there's just the
floor right they can't be younger than
six weeks um you know that happens on a
one-year-old room a two-year-old room
and older you can move them up and down
a little bit provided everything's safe
Mom and Dad knows um your ratio is based
on your average
age so you're there's there's ways in
those older rooms but in the infant room
specifically you're talking about you
when you start doing the math right um
there's no people are not making money
inant room this is not going to make
infant rooms suddenly super profitable
um but what I will hope it will do is I
hope it will people that are looking at
their chalkra Center I hope that it will
encourage them to expand that if it's an
opportunity um and we just need to have
a good faith conversation about is that
2 to9 ratio right is that significantly
worse than 2 to8 right cuz once again we
are not talking about 1: four going to 1
to five we're talking about 2 to8 going
to 2 to9 um and with that I'm happy to
to take the
questions thank you for accepting
questions
representative thank you so I learn
things every day in this role but uh I
my children attended a daycare and I
think that they over enrolled because
they were bumping my children into the
one's room sometime they spend a day so
now I know what happened but um so um I
like this bill um and I just wanted to
clarify that nothing will require a
child care provider to even change their
ratios they just can if they're willing
and they have the staff and they think
they can take on whe whether it be for
space or fire code this is something
that allows them to accept another child
okay thank you correct so so none of the
other regulations change right if the
room is not because it's basically like
40 square foot per children um per child
excuse me
um that's that none of that changes
right if your room can only hold eight
you don't get to magically hold nine now
if your room so like my infant room is I
believe it's licensed up to 11: we will
never go to 11 because I need to get to
12 right to be I need to get to 12 to
break even right so like I have this
three child extra capacity in my Center
I'll never use it um right and I'm not
by the way I'm not advocating for that
um this thing this change only allows
for that first bump up so it's not like
you can start like putting in I've got
like six teachers in and now I can go
plus seven um it's plus one teacher plus
one student one time cut off um and to
that point I I reiterate you know if
every Childcare Center in the Capac in
the state had a capacity to go to nine
in a room we would be immediately
increasing the access if every child
care center enrolled in this process we
would immediately be increasing the
access um 12 a half% for infant care um
and market market economics will tell
you right as you increase Supply right
price comes down right um because we
know the Dem demand's there we don't
have to worry about the demand we know
the demand's there um but as you
increase Supply price will come down and
the question we have to have go back to
it and we have to have a good faith
conversation is is is this safe to what
level is it going to affect quality I'm
not going to sit up here and tell you
there will be no quality difference
between a and N of course there will be
a quality diminish of course there will
be right the question is is what is the
tradeoff of that what level of quality
is diminished I personally don't believe
it's very much but it'll be something um
versus what is the cost of having that
parent not in the workforce or having
that child at home um we do know that a
child is more likely to get into an
accident home they are in a Childcare
Center that's a fact right so these are
things that the committee needs to have
an honest conversation about um and I I
obviously I'm for it I sponsored it um
but I I really want to emphasize like I
I hope that there's not the like you
know this is going to you know kids are
going to be in trouble like like let's
not have that let's not have the
hysteria let's just have an actual
conversation about specifically for
infant care now this this is all levels
but specifically for infant care is that
12 and a half increase with that second
teacher in the room that's secondhand
available to you is that going having
that extra child in there with them is
that going to diminish the care versus
is it worth it to have whatever that
diminished care is is it worth it to
have that 12 a half% expansion of that
access
followup I this may be standard RSA
stuff but this act shall take effect 60
days after its passage I love the
immediacy of this as a solution is it
possible to have it take effect
immediately after the governor
presumably signs it into law or is that
not possible I that's a question for
exec I would say yes um we kind of 60
days of standard stock language I will
say the uh something to point out the
ratios are not currently in statute the
ratios are currently in rule um so what
we what I did was I take for those
who've ever followed me I'm a big fan of
the legislator taking back the rul
making Authority um like I know it's I'm
a big fan of that I think it's actually
our job to do that as much as possible
so what I did was I took the existing
rules and I just codify basically take
our power back and codify it because we
give uh dhss the power to make rules but
ultimately we are the deciders of what
happens uh and I got into a very heated
argument about that with representative
Hill the other day um about we are we do
actually get to make the
rules
thank you representative Phillips good
questions good question from you too I'm
sure representative
crate thank you Sher thank you for
taking my question um it's actually is a
little bit similar to a question that
representative Phillips asked earlier um
would it make sense to Sunset this
change um if we get to a point where uh
with this and all of the other changes
that we're making to enhance child care
availability and and spots and
everything um so that it's not such a
emergency could we go back in 5 years or
revisit this so I'm totally open to that
and I actually thought about putting it
in there to begin with um because it is
it is a it is something that would
normally fall underne the ru making
Authority um but I'm I'm totally open to
that um I would even be open to some
trigger right you know if and we can
really get into the Weeds on it but you
know if there's some survey that is
conducted because they they they conduct
regular childcare surveys there's some
survey that conducted and it shows that
there's you know X number of openings
then this this law shall Sunset
immediately or something like that I'm
totally open to it I'm totally open to
it thank you representative Paige and
then back to you representative Phillips
thank you madam chair so I'm curious if
you talk directly to providers who want
this increase um one of the
things so we I've seen two different
different surveys at this point looking
at this issue and in both cases it was
clear that a majority of providers do
not want this change but also that
there's like 30% or so of providers who
are
interested something that's interesting
to me is I haven't heard the voices of
that 30% directly and I don't know if
that's because they know they're in the
minority and they don't feel comfortable
speaking up about it but I'm wondering
if you as the
sponsor have heard directly from those
providers about why they want this
change about the impact on quality
um because if we're contemplating this I
really want to understand what those
what that Minority of providers is
hoping to achieve and how how they think
that they can do this without a
meaningful compromise on quality that
will be a detriment to our kids and Care
yeah so I definitely have spoken to
providers who want the ratios increase
there's some providers that want no no
ratios like we we ain't going we we
going to get there so like you know um
let's like let's not let's not be silly
um but I think when it comes to so when
it comes to the Quality uh I will say as
a provider myself a conversation I've
had with other providers the largest
concern like I'm not overly concerned
about the diminished quality of the
child I'm worried about the staff um so
I asked I pulled my staff in the in the
childcare room I said hey uh what would
you think if I tossed a ninth kid in
here and they're like uh you know okay I
was like what what would what would you
think if I toss ninth kitten here and I
paid you $2 an hour more oh yes yeah
yeah bring the ninth kitten um
so it's it's you know I I I think you
have to let the my greatest concern is
that employer employee relationship
right um I you know I I really view my
employee I try to treat them like really
well like it's literally a part of my
business model I've talked about here my
my business model is uh very high
retention treat my employees very well
um right way easier like replacing
replacing good employees it cost me like
thousands of dollars to do that I don't
even want to do it it's just I I want
them to stay forever I know they won't
but I want them to stay forever um so my
largest concern would be a employer that
opts into this would need to be very
wary of what sort of Burden are they
placing on the actual childcare employee
um I would go back to they don't have to
do it right um when I asked once again
I'll go back to when I asked my my
Center uh when I asked my teachers you
know they were like they weren't really
hot on the ninth kid and when I said I'd
PID them more money they were like
absolutely bring them on in so you know
I think that's a conversation that
employees employers need to have
um you know giving my staff in that room
a $2 raise and then adding in another
kid um would allow me to actually lower
the overall cost for the rest of the
parents um and I I would everybody would
win the CH the cost for the parents
would go down I would make more money my
employer my employees would make more
money everybody's happy across the board
um but that's a decision that I would
make as a business owner um the decision
that we have to make as a state is is it
safe and to what level is it diminished
quality um personally I believe it is
safe obviously if I thought it was safe
I wouldn't even propose the idea I think
to your point about why more employe why
more people don't speak up about it is
it it takes a level of bravery to say
hey I think we can put more kids in this
classroom because of the blowback you
know you're going to get um because you
can see the accusations that are going
to get pointed oh you don't care about
the kids you just want to make money
right no employee no no small business
owner wants to raise their hand and have
that conversation um but I I assure you
it exists and I assure you looking at
the overall Market as a whole I'll go
back to if you want to create a relief
valve the the largest relief valve that
you can create for the existing problems
that we have in child care right is this
it's the largest release of valve
because it's increased Revenue right
without increasing costs it is the only
thing that you can do right um across
the board and we just have to have a an
once again go back to an honest
conversation about is it safe is is the
diminish I'm not going to sit here in
lie and say that the care is going to be
the same is the is the the amount that
the care will go down right is the
divided attention that it'll go down is
it worth the increase in Access and
affordability personally I believe
yes representative Phillips thank you
again is there a state that you're
modeling these ratios a after I know
that Massachusetts you mentioned earlier
is actually more conservative and I'll
never say that again uh in their ratios
so they do 3 to one so is there another
state that's doing this at this level or
or more so there are states that have
higher ratios than this um their states
that historically we have not modeled
ourselves after you know I think
Mississippi's in there um you know I I
looked at it I kind of looked at like
where we were um where the state was and
you know we are on probably kind of
already I wouldn't say we're in the high
end but we're probably above
50%
um once again it's a question of do we
keep going up right to allow more kids
in um because we know there's nothing
else that we're going to be able to do
today that would actually increase
access um but no we're not like I
wouldn't I think I want to say there was
one state that had like one to six and I
was like even I was like jaw dropped on
that I'm like that's insane um but it's
you know I would never I I couldn't I
couldn't see a world in which we would
go to one of six I wouldn't see I
wouldn't even recommend going to one to
five uh Standalone teacher um but I do
think 2 to nine um is acceptable um
because as I said earlier when the the
infants when they all for some reason
they all like they all go together like
they're all asleep together or they're
all they're all awake together doing
what the infants do um so it is a very
stressful room it's a very loud room um
it takes a special special special
teacher to go into that room every day
um you are dealing in literal human
feces on an Al I me you're doing you
know you're doing all the things a mom
does times four um for eight hours
straight um God bless those people God
bless
them any further
questions representative wner yes so I
looking at the bill and all of these
ratios only deal with children under
three years old so we're not y you
didn't look at the preschool preschool
ratios correct I did not um and the what
reason being once again I know this is
already a big pill to swallow um I from
my from my conversations and our
hearings there is not as big of a need
in those higher those higher rooms those
rooms already have you know 12 to1
ratios right um once you get up there
you have more access you definitely have
more affordability I didn't believe it
was necessary if you wanted to go all
the way up trust me the conservative in
me would would would agree to that but I
I tried to start I tried to instead of
trying to start the bill all the way to
the right and work to the middle I just
said I'm going to come with I what I
think is the actual middle right off the
bat um because I don't some somebody
will probably say I'm wrong I just don't
believe we need to change the ratios for
the older kids right now because I just
don't see the level of Crisis there that
I do for the under
threes have a follow
up so I guess I'm reading the bill and I
think um section three mhm I'm wondering
if it is incorrect or if this really
what you met prob not the um the ratio
now is
one teacher for every six children and I
assumed you were doing multiples of two
you would add one yeah so next on B it's
one associate teacher one assistant with
up to 12 that's did you really mean 13
there uh probably did once once again it
wasn't my uh wasn't my it wasn't my
focus I was focused down below so yeah
if if we want to fix it or we want well
I just wonder I just wondered if it was
to I'm totally down to fix it um once my
focus really is the most book of test my
focus is that infant room um because
that's that's where the biggest B that's
where the biggest burden is so it total
I would not surprise me if after after
one years old there were errors because
my focus is I'm like laser beamed on
that infant room I have one more
question
certainly I was wondering
how and maybe there's someone in the
audience who will come later and you can
who will testify to this how does this
fit with the um fire Life Safety codes
yep so as I said in the testimony like
this can't override the fire safety
codes right how it fits in I don't know
but it can't override it um I said that
in the testimony and we we've had that
conversation before about we can't just
because DHHS or I guess now the law
would say you can have nine in there if
the fire code says eight guess what it's
eight like that's just what it is so you
haven't check we haven't checked this
no proposed law against what the fire
codes now say no I I I've dealt with the
I've I've have I filled the fire code
with this committee I'm sure we'd have
to look at it at some point but my
intention is not to override the fire
code okay thank you because I I that's
once again it's a safety conversation
that I don't I'm really trying to stay
as far away from that as possible
because that would be the quick death of
this thank you for obvious
reasons
any further
questions seeing none thank you
representative
Barry um the next card I have is for uh
Lynn wette she's representing
herself
hi hi thank you for um taking the time
to hear my testimony so although I don't
agree don't disagree with representative
Barry that it would give us a little
more economic impact as a director um my
infants don't eat sleep and eat at the
same time they're up all day long um my
office is directly located next to there
I can't tell you that I don't have a
baby in my lap and and no picture on a
zoom meeting cuz I'm feeding someone are
helping out because it's a constant flow
in that room um and although the
economic impact might be helpful I just
don't see putting that extra sta stress
on a staff that are already stressed out
they're already working eight nine hours
a day um I don't over enroll I don't
over enroll for a reason because my
children need
consistency um if I'm popping a
one-year-old into the 2-year-old room
because their age appropriate but
because I'm over enrolled in my
one-year-old room that's not fair to
that child um and it's not fair to that
family because they're never getting
settled with the teacher and the same
with babies babies need consistent
caregivers and the more you add to a
classroom the harder it is on the people
in that classroom and I mean I'm in
ratio I have an eight an 8 to2 so I have
eight babies two teachers and there are
multiple times that I am that third set
of hands to help out because they don't
all eat and sleep at the same time um
they do what they want to do when they
want to do it and they're as cute as can
be but they're in charge and we are not
and kind of the same with my ones and
twos even though there's a little bit
more
schedule I can't imagine asking my
teachers to take one more child um even
if it was $2 I just can't imagine asking
them and I do think it will is it going
to be a big factor in the quality no but
it is going to have some imp impact and
our kids deserve to have the highest
quality they possibly
can thank you thank you can I ask you a
question sure so do you agree that um
would you agree that uh in this uh bill
it doesn't say that a child care
facility has to increase to those ratios
but in some cases some um facilities
might want to
so I think that we have to look at it as
what's best for all children thank you
not what's best for us as the
adults thank
you have any more C cards does anybody
here have any questions we have the blue
sheet
please representative wer um the
licensing people are here they probably
don't have an opinion on the bill or
want to voice one but I do want to know
if how this fits with the fire safety
codes and the life safety
codes hello meliss thank you for coming
forward Melissa sure thank you um thank
you representative Al for the question
but that's a question for the State Fire
Marshall's office I am not prepared to
answer for them because it's the state
fire code so thank
you is there anyone here from the fire
no they're watching they're watching
okay so they
may as an architect who deals with the
same kind of square footage limitations
uh rep Barry's testimony was accurate
that if you have a room that the square
footage is acceptable for 11 children
but you only have the staff to do a
certain number you cannot ceed the
square footage and that would Trump this
legislation so if you're only allowed to
have say seven children in the room then
you may by this legislation be allowed
to have nine with the two adults but you
can still only have seven because the
square footage doesn't need that
okay um just one um clarification
representative MC Williams in in
addition to the square footage for State
Fire codes I do know they also have have
client what they call client to staff
ratios so they also have a ratio in
their fire code related to children and
staff it's not just the square footage
but I'll let them speak to the
specificities just for clarification
this bill in no way will compete with
those fire codes so you have any further
question oh I just was going to say to
the fire code people who are out there
listening could they could they please
could they please provide those to us
thank you thank you for that question I
apologize that they cannot answer you
directly but I'm sure we will hear
some uh information from them they
they're um very dedicated thank
you any further
questions
turn this thing back on I do have the
blue sheet there
are uh
one six people signed up on the blue
sheet five of them are uh con and one
did not disclose so thank you
all and with that I will close the
hearing on uh House Bill
1407 and uh if uh chair Barry is in the
hallway can he duck his head in and let
us know when we should
reconvene how much time would you like
for lunch representative
Barry
yeah I think that's the reason what time
is it right now it's uh 12:40 yeah yeah
so let's uh let's pick this back up um
let's pick this back up at 1:30 um and
then
uh English I keep trying to want to call
you Rebecca it's very rude
representative MC Williams were you able
to submit that to OS thank you chair
Barry everyone present in in this
committee room was copied on the email
to OSS I've asked for it by 2 o'clock
that may be a miracle for them but if
we're running late maybe that's okay all
right so we'll see everybody back at
1:30 thank
you
e
jeez yeah this one this one's this is a
fun one um this is a fun
one I think this is just straight up me
yep
okay and the vice chair is gone
chairman because I am the sole sponsor
of this bill so I have to introduce it
um so I don't have anyone I can hand the
chair off to right now
so there she is okay she's
back all
right
all
I'm going to open the hearing on House
Bill
1409 and I'll call on representative
Ross Barry from Hillsboro 39
to excuse me to bring his bill to order
okay thank you madam chairman my name is
representative Ross Bay represent
Manchester's a 689 the fighting South
End as I like to say um and uh I'm here
to introduce hp1 1409 so let me talk
about the intent of the bill because I'm
sure if we decide to move forward with
it at all it'll be modified probably
dramatically um but my intent of the
bill is to further involve and further
codify the child the child care advisory
committee into dhs's Ru making process
so the
the intention of this is obvious right
the childcare committee is composed of
major stakeholders inside of the
childcare industry um and having them be
a integral part of this
um it just seems logical right so
there's going to be some things that uh
probably will be said they're going to
reference a court case from
1981 um that says the legislature cannot
uh dictate rulemakings um author dict
the legislature cannot control the
executive Branch's rule making Authority
when the legislature gives away the
rulemaking authority uh it's a deeply
flawed decision from over 40 years ago
that will likely be overturned the
moment any uh of us want to challenge it
um as I said earlier um we are the
legislator we control these things um
when we give away rul making Authority
we have every we are well within our
rights to control how that is given away
um to say otherwise is actually a deeply
flawed uh way of thinking so um I didn't
really run I I spoke offhandedly with
the child advisory committee about this
um I I wouldn't say they signed off on
it I just said Hey what if I submitted
this uh and kind of well yeah we'll talk
about it I said all right well almost
submit it um so basically if the DHHS
proposes new rules uh the um the child
care ad oh I'm sorry we're on the wrong
bill um jeez I'm on the wrong one um
um am I no I'm on the right pill sorry
I'm like so out of it right now I can't
do these things after lunch I did the
problem is I didn't uh um there we go
I've taken
um so this is the um I'm talking about I
am talking about something differently
um no no I am I'm on the rules making
God I am so out of it y'all I did I for
the record I did nine hours in election
all yesterday so my brain is really gone
um no so we are talk uh if they they
they can look at this they can look at
the basically the rule the ru making the
rules that are proposed and they can say
yes no before it moves on um I do think
I do think you know currently the
legislator doesn't have the ability to
like say no um this is not giving the
legislature that ability um which was my
step around the 1981 decision um but I
do think we have this legislative
enacted body that is composed of
stakeholders chalk Care Center owners
people that have been in the industry
for a very long time people with deep
knowledge um and I think having them be
a part of proposed rule making not to
say that DHHS doesn't already consult
them I know that dhh does consult with
them I know that DHHS does talk to them
um I'm not saying that that line of
communication doesn't already exist but
what I would like to see is that
childcare advisory committee to have
some teeth to it so if they are really
adamantly against something that DHHS is
proposing they can be like no we're not
going to do that it's bad for the
industry it's bad bad for you know the
quality or whatever reason they want to
do it um you know that that committee
that committee is comprised of people I
imagine they probably get along with
DHHS most of the time um but I do think
I do think it's important that the
providers the Childcare Center owners
the people inside the industry have a
deeper understanding of what's going
into this um something we need to take a
look at is I know that DHHS is in the
middle of a rewrite of all of the rules
um
I don't know where they are in that
process I imagine they're probably
getting near the end of it um one of the
things that they had talked about that
they were doing um was basically
streamlining it to make the rules more
understandable um and I think one of the
things they'll probably talk to it about
it I think one of the things they're
doing was separating It Out by license
types so you didn't so if you were
opening up an at home center you were
only looking at the atome center rules
and not the rules for the the different
license types um so those sort of things
um I think we would probably need to
delay the enactment because I think DHHS
does need to finish that work um and I
know they are working with the childcare
advisoring committee on that um so I
don't want to interrupt that process but
after that process is done I would like
to see a formal codification of the
industry being involved in the rulle
making process from the legislator so
with that um happy to take any questions
I I I know this thing will need work uh
if we even decide to go forward with it
I'm not I myself I'm not dead set on it
um but uh definitely a conversation I
think worth having
will you take questions oh yeah
representative Paige thank you madam
chair so reading the
bill and listening to your testimony I'm
I'm seeing a little bit of a disconnect
and maybe it's a misunderstanding and
reading reading it but you know what I'm
what I am hearing you say is having the
council have input into the promulgation
of new rules yeah right whereas what I'm
reading in the bill is that it's a role
in the appeal process yeah I am sorry it
it is the first bill that I was thinking
of and not the second um I apologize
about that no this is this is this is
the one I thought I was on um so this is
the one about the appeals process for
for when there's a of finding a
violation um which is another thing that
we have to have a conversation of so
right now if you're found in violation
sorry I got like five Child Care bills
um if they found in
violation um you can appeal to DHHS you
can get an administrative rules hearing
they have a process outline for that in
RSA um but you really are just kind of
at the mercy of the bureaucracy um so
this would put you into the mercy of the
childcare advisory committee if they
wanted it um my guess is they may or may
not want it um but I think it's worth
you know if you have a violation and you
want to appeal to you know if you if
your lenser finds you in violation and
you appeal to the licenser supervisor
right and then you appeal to the
director right you haven't really you
haven't really ever gone into a new
third party to kind of I don't want to
say arbitrate but let's say um get a
second opinion right um they're they're
they can say what they want but they're
they're probably going to be predisposed
to reinforcing the finding um this would
put it in front of the chare advisory
committee if you wanted to appeal it um
it's a way kind of talking about earlier
I want to make it to where the industry
is more self-re ating um and that's
that's what this is follow
up so thank you for that clarification
um so as you envision the council's role
here the way I'm reading this is that
there is
review and presentation of
recommendations but we're not giving any
kind of decision-making Authority in the
appeals process correct so it's more
just another voice at the
table is that yeah that's where we're
headed to I I want the like I said I
know the bill is not done um but that's
I want I want a third party involved in
this process when there is a finding um
if the if they decide to contest the
findings um and there's times when you
want to contest the findings there's
times you say yeah I messed up and you
moved on um but you know there are times
when I think I can give you an example
like they accused me of not having
background checks done we had done all
the background checks they just weren't
linked on the NH connections website
well the finding said we hadn't done
background checks well we had done
background checks everybody had their
cards right so that would be an example
of you know hey uh we had the background
checks everybody's fine um they're just
not connected on the website so the
finding the finding there doesn't match
the the public stated finding doesn't
match what actually happened so in these
sort of situations uh we need to create
we need to have a third party in there
to say hey like what's actually going on
here um because you don't you really
don't have a if you are caught in a
finding you don't really have a out you
can't really get outside of the DHHS
framework to help
you representative MC Williams thank you
madam chair um thank you very much
representative Barry for bringing
forward this bill um I would say that
this is probably the most important
issue that was discussed when we did a
study on the business of child care
and uh impediments to succeeding in the
business of child care um I suppose this
is a would you believe but uh would you
believe that the board of realators has
a really interesting uh arbitration
process for analyzing how things are
dealt with internally and getting a
second opinion so that it's not just one
department is judge jury and executioner
which uh was a direct quote from some of
the testimony we heard about five years
ago from Child Care businesses who
really felt like they were being singled
out and accused of things that were not
necessarily based on the facts uh and
also uh perhaps being singled out and
continued to be singled out in repeat uh
alleged violations that turned into
perhaps losing their business I I I
would definitely believe that and I'm I
I hadn't even thought to look at how the
reals uh would do it as a potential
framework obviously this thing is not
done um just one of those uh I'm a big
fan of amendments so because if you can
get an amendment pass you can usually
get a bill pass so um it definitely
would be something that I would love to
look into to see if there's already a
pre-established framework the other
thing we need to do is figure how to do
the childcare advisory Council even
wants this Duty uh they may say no to it
it's very possible and then we have to
go figure out something else if we want
to do something um but I do think there
needs to be a third party involved here
um the childcare advisor Council was
just the um immediate obvious choice um
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
they want to be the choice so they might
they might say absolutely not we don't
want to do that totally their business
any further questions for the
representative thank you representative
very good job I look forward to not
getting my bills confused when we do do
the rules one that'll be fun one too I'm
sure you'll do better I'll Advocate on
that one as well I'll be
outside
okay while we're mentioning lunch I just
want to make an announcement it's
probably going to be easier this
afternoon since we've hopefully all had
lunch already but according to house
rules you're not to have anything to eat
or drink other than water while in this
room so if you need to eat and a lot of
people do please step out of the room if
you need to drink anything other than
water please step out of the room um and
hopefully uh we won't get into any
trouble so I thank you for that and the
next person that has asked to be uh able
to be heard is uh
Maran barter and you've asked for two
minutes there you go thank you certainly
hi I'm Maran barter I'm the chair of the
New Hampshire childcare advisory Council
and certainly we you know we we exist to
serve so if we're asked to fill this
role we can but I I hope that the
committee thinks about our
capacity right now the childcare
advisory Council has one paid staff
member and we're entirely volunteers
otherwise so we really don't have the
capacity to take on a something that has
the chance of being as large as this one
thing we could do is work with childcare
licensing to create a peerreview group
and to facilitate that process and that
feels like something as um
representative MC Williams mentioned
that the field would be interested in
that they feel strongly about um and a
way to work with our DHHS Partners to
make sure everything is done in a
systemic way that can give it the true
gravitas that it needs that's
it thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you so
much the next people I'd like to call
forward is Melissa Clement and
Danielle
woro come on up and have a
seat okay um thank you madam chair for
the record I'm Melissa Clement I'm the
chief of the childcare licensing unit
after listening to representative
Barry's testimony we don't feel we need
our legal council it was our legal
council was going to come up because
based on what we saw in the bill we
thought that the intent was to have
another process after a re when we
revoked a license finded a program so
something and we already have a very
robust appeals process so it sounds more
like what he is looking for um um is
what we call after our informal dispute
resolution process so what that means is
we've cited a program for a citation the
program receives it does not feel that
they were actually in violation of that
rule so then they appeal it to our
office we have what's called an informal
dispute resolution process which we then
get decided and then after that I
believe what he's trying to propose is
another once we've made our decision
that there's another outside entity that
will then review our decision and the
facts and make another determination and
bring that forth to the department and
we are in favor of that we have been
working with the childcare advisory
Council on revising our rules and we
have already started the conversations
of what is called an independent
informal dispute resolution process
which we are proposing to put in rule um
this when we're revising our rules now
and we will um be modeling it after what
is happens in the adult licensing of
facilities so they have a process
process that comes to them from the
federal government we have an internal
State process that we're going to model
it on so we are in the process of doing
that and the rules will be completed
this year so we plan to move
forward and I'll happy to take any
questions any
questions representative crean thank you
chair thank you for taking my question
um I'm curious so in this process that
you're in the process that you're in the
process of developing um uh who are the
sort of outside folks that you're
looking to get involved in this we're
already in the middle of it so the
childcare advisory Council actually
worked with us to create a group of
child care providers so they're across
the state they're all across different
types of childcare programs so they've
all been part of this process as we're
going through and revising the rules
great
follow thank you um so with that in
mind are you saying that you feel like
there's not a need to put this into
statute because there's something
already happening or okay that just to
make sure I have that I I believe that
would be obviously that would be my
recommendation because we we are doing
it thank you for the
question any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and my final pink card is Jacqueline
Cowell come on
up hi good afternoon I'm Jackie Cowell
from Early Learning New Hampshire um our
organization has two voting seats on the
legislatively enacted childcare advisory
Council and I basically ditto what
Maryann barter the chair and uh Melissa
Clement said the only thing I would just
sort of share in terms of um I've been
in this field for a long time and
sometimes the childcare advisory council
is listened to and is is actually a real
genuine adviser and sometimes they're
not you know depending on who's who's
who and who's where and so I just think
you know I I love the fact that you know
with with Chief Melissa Clement and
chair Maryann barter they've got a great
strong relationship so that M you know
they're seating they're seating the
panel that's working on the rules and
reaching out directly to the field to do
that but there have been times where
it's been really tough so I'm think just
thinking having if there is going to be
a peer review board or something like
that like I think Board of Nursing has
something like that which I the field
does definitely as representative MC
Williams says is very eager to have some
kind of a peerreview panel of some sort
I do think it's a good idea not for the
childcare advisory Council to be the
panel but to help seat that panel that
would be my
recommendation thank you any
questions seeing
represent thank you um would you Echo
the recommendation of the previous
speaker that this is not needed in
statute that we can deal with this
strictly through rulemaking
yes thank you any further
questions thank you very
much seeing no further pink cards I will
now close the hearing on uh uh House
Bill
1409 if representative Barry is out in
the hallway and would like to come on
in
1409 blue sheet
please do you need time no no just
trying to do that whole like yeah three
things at once life I I have any more
bills thank
God all right and we're back according
to the blue sheet uh on House Bill
1409 the four people signed up with um
not disclosing Pro or con all right so
that
was okay so that was
1409 right see if I can keep my bill
numbers right this time all right 1567
Rel all right so I'm going to open uh
it's 130 just checking y uh going to
open up the public hearing on House Bill
1567 FN relative to zoning Provisions
concerning family and group family child
care uses uh oh grasses already up there
um is is that what you were saying about
making that joke committee running
behind I mean we are we are we are we
are we are I'm supposed to be an
executive session upstairs so okay well
I'll tell you
what we will get you going I apologize
we'll get you going thank you welcome to
the special commit on shock
representative thank you I'm represent
for the Recon of Representative Chuck
grassy from Rochester straford 8 and I'm
here to introduce the bill uh basically
House Bill 1567
which is relative to zoning Provisions
concerning family and group child Family
Care uses um first I mean I'm sure you
guys have heard all the information but
back in 2004 there was actually a study
this is 2004 remember this dollars and
cents wise this was just for the central
New Hampshire District that said Child
Care enables parents to collect collect
wages of $156 million annually just to
Central New
Hampshire central New Hampshire Regional
planning districts can't give you the
the towns that they were but the thing
is this is a study that's available um
did take me a little work to get the
executive summary on it a friend of mine
actually did this study when she worked
with the Department with for that
planning agency that pointed out the
value of child care to the state of New
Hampshire over the last couple of years
I've had the um working uh with folks or
being at social events with childcare
workers because my wife happens to be a
childcare worker and um I always ran
into this problem of people saying you
know we're having problems locating our
childcare in our community specific
community and it was everywhere in the
state of New Hampshire and I said well
you know I think I may know what the
problem is as a planner back in the late
80s I also was involved with zoning
changes and site review and subdivision
changes and one of the things is at the
time we would saying how do we deal with
childcare I says well easy solution
let's make them home
occupations big mistake uh because as
soon as home inome home occupations now
they're subjected to the regulations of
um hours of operation outdoor storage of
equipment uh parking requirements um you
know and when they when Neighbors come
in and start complaining about you know
what type of fence you need uh I mean a
lot of this stuff is dealt with in HHS
regulations already for certified
childcare centers so you know what I'm
seeing here is that um people are not
locating because they're having problems
of paying $1,000 to have a survey or
survey their property to meet the
requirements of a local review requ
having a lawyer having to attend a
meeting to present their case for him
before a local planning board um the
requirements that a planning board can
put through site review can be quite
honorous one of the things that I know
the legislature did in the past is they
said that you couldn't that you couldn't
Zone Child Care out they didn't say
anything about site review that seems to
be where the problem was when I
submitted this bill in originally I had
put it under RSA
6721 and I found out after I had
somebody review it they said uh Ben
Frost you probably know Ben he's a old
friend of mine from the plan my planning
years as well and he said you know
something the zoning provision that we
have in the rsas is in an aspirational
section of the or of the RSA so really
it has very little enforcement Authority
you need to put it in the implementation
section and that's why under 67416 is
where we ended up doing this and what I
did is we've got sort of like belts and
suspenders here not only is both the
zoning which previously passed by the
legislature but my provision to
exempt small child care facilities from
site review are both in 672 the
aspirational section and 674 the
implementation section so that when a
planning when a childcare wants to open
they will not have to go before a
planning board and spend what could be
thousands of dollars and what happens in
most cases they just don't go uh they
end up operating without um a license in
many cases
and you'll see many communities you'll
say there are no family child care or
group family child carees in this
community there may be they're just not
licensed and that's the problem that we
have we want to make sure our our
licensing is provides for safe and
affordable child care um one of the
things my son happens to be the director
of the National Guards uh Family Support
Services here in New Hampshire and one
of the things they're looking for
National Guard uh they look for child
care for the National Guard people who
work who have have weekend duties
or the twoe duty whatever and the thing
is is that they need to be
licensed and this is one of the problems
we're having he cannot contract with a
non-licensed child care also they need
weekends larger childcare centers don't
work on weekends in fact they don't work
after six o'clock in most cases it's
difficult to find Child Care on weekends
and and after certain hours family child
care and group family child are the only
places that can happen and that's the
only only cases is provide when we had a
we had a a family chalk here at my house
we used to take a lot of the nurses from
the local hospital and many times we had
the nurse saying I'm going into a
surgery it's probably going to be
difficult I don't know what time I'm
going to get out you can't call a center
and say that but you can call a family
child care or a group family child you
can call them and they will provide the
services for you they will provide
weekend Services you they will provide
overnight services for you we don't have
that available to us in many cases right
now because not all they're not being
driven out by zoning but they' be driven
about excessive cost and requirements
that site review has now this bill does
not deal with building inspectors or
fire inspectors those people are still
going to exist and there's still going
to be a pain in the butt to most
childcare
workers most childcare centers can I not
say
that you can say that again and again if
you want to say it louder turn the
volume I I I know but you know and and
the thing is is that the thing is
they're still there this is just the
first First Step you know if we need to
deal with other things we'll we'll work
on that next but let's see if we can get
to make Child Care truly affordable and
to allow people to open up that want to
open up centers in communities where
there is a need you folks all I'm
speaking the choir when I say there is a
need out there we all know that and we
all know what the what the financial
impl implications are of not having
adequate Child Care safe licensed child
care in the state of New Hampshire and I
would I have a number of people that
will be speaking here uh that have uh
that have childcare centers here in the
state of New Hampshire and talking about
it and most of you already know these
issues this is just one step um I you
know I was with Mary Jane and when she
said you know how are we going to deal
with this problem I says we'll just
eliminate site review Provisions she
said that'll never happen and when I got
representative Barry as a closep so I
said yes it will
happen I'll be happy to answer any of
your questions we okay perfect
representa D
Simone thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and please give
my best to your wife Ann it was a
pleasure serving with her on children
and family law I certainly will thank
you if she doesn't yell at me after
watching this so no I'm sure she
won't further I apologize I thought you
were just being nice please ask your
question I'm so sorry it was so rude of
me no you're okay I I'll forgive you I'm
in a forgiving
mood right now any um my question to you
is can you explain the difference
between the permitting process and the
licensing process because they're two
different animals right well I'm not
sure what you mean I know the permitting
process from from a planning board as a
town planner I'm not sure about the
licensing process I know there are a
number of regulations there are people
here that can speak on that and that
licensing has a lot of the requirements
that most planting Woods would be
already looking at such as how much land
area you have to have and when you come
into a planning board you say I want to
open up a childcare um I'm going to have
six kids I want to open up a childcare
in my community what happens is is that
you fill out all these forms you have to
provide plans of your building and the
area that you're going to use you have
to take a look at their regulations and
sometimes they're going to ask you what
have your what are your hours of
operations because the neighbors are
going to complain if you you're
operating overnight I don't know what
having maybe two kids that end up
spending the night because a mother is
working is going to be a problem I mean
if the Brady Bunch were living in that
house it would be much more of a problem
than having two kids that spend the
night with you where you may have two of
your own um and and but they're going to
ask you those questions they're going to
say that there are regulations you can't
have any outside storage of equipment
that's an normal so in other words that
swing set that you put up you have to
take down every night um you know these
are just some of the things they can do
they're going to require that if you
have a non- relative employee you're
going to have to have parking um you
know you may have to have so many
parking spaces per the number of kids
you have I don't know what their
regulations could be but it could be
it's nebulous what they could have for
requirements in their zoning and review
regulations and what this does is
they're already exempts childcare is
already exempt from from zoning now
there's the site review to continue on
with what the question you ask they will
be required to come to a meeting they
will possibly ask to provide a site plan
which means they have to get a survey
done of their property and heaven forbid
they have Wetlands on that property that
could be further out back and they may
have to actually get a wetland scientist
to identify those Wetlands that may be
well off where the play area is going to
be but that's what the rules require now
that could be thousands of dollars
right there then they've got all their
neighbors get notified that they're
going to have six kids at their house
during the day or maybe even on a
Saturday or a Sunday and the thing is
that all those Neighbors come in and
start complaining about what about all
that parking that's going to happen
they're going to jam up the streets uh
with with parking for these six kids
it's going to be impossible it's going
to be like going down the local school
where there you 50 cars lined up in
front of the house I'm surprised nobody
said you'd have to have one parking
space per child on your
property but you know these are the
requirements that they go through and
then when you get that now the person's
already said okay my neighbors hate me
probably the best thing is to not open
this childcare or move and then so they
don't apply they they drop out of the
out of the
process and what what happens is is that
they will probably six months later open
without being certified without getting
certification from the state and without
the knowledge of the local planning
board or local or the town and then
maybe somebody will complain because
they see three extra kids in there and
you know the situation is they're my
friend's kids they're over to play with
it's a play date you know it's not a
child care you know you you put them
into situations like that which are
totally you know we shouldn't be doing
that and when you're taking a look at
Family childcare and group family child
care um you know we looked at the
regulations when we were going through
this and I talked with the people in the
field and they said those are the two
that we're really concerned about mostly
because of the flexibility that they
have somebody has a big piece of land
they may have have a barn that they can
use for child you know for some
activities in the winter time or
whatever or in inclement weather and
they can have a group family child care
or if they've got a smaller place they
can have a child care it says and it
also says in the law that as it's
proposed it says that it has to be
located in as an accessory use anywhere
where a residential use is allowed
accessory use which means the primary
use has to be a residence so somebody
can't buy a house I know people have
said could we do that that you may want
to amend the bill say it doesn't have to
be an accessory use that it could be
just a house in a neighborhood the bill
that I put in was just a small step and
I think it's a Light Lift very easy lift
for this committee to say yes on this
bill because it says it has to be an
accessory use in other words the people
would have to live in the property in
order to have this
so further questions from the committee
I I'll hit you with the would you
believe uh would gra would you believe
uh that I view
um uh family and group and group Family
Care Centers as one of the major
solutions to the child care crisis
especially in our rural
communities certainly and I'll tell you
that working with my wife who works for
the Rochester Childcare Center now as a
family Outreach coordinator there I mean
one of the things that they do people
look at this is that well that's
competition no it's not because they
have no spaces they cannot provide the
service the large centers have run out
of space and they're looking at this and
they also have the the inability to be
flexible
um you know this is something that yes
this is very important I mean this will
provide a tremendous assistance to our
child care uh opportunities here in the
state of New
Hampshire further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative grassy I look forward to
this one as you can
imagine I appreciate your uh allowing me
to partner on to it um next up Jackie
Cowell
hi I'm Jackie KY from Early Learning New
Hampshire I'll be very brief I agree
with Jen leer who's going to be coming
up here soon with her testimony she's
more of an expert on this bill but I
really want to commend uh Jer and the
team of of legislators and others who
really really asked the field what was
necessary it wasn't just somebody his
idea and it was really well- mind and
really well thought out so we do support
this bill excellent next up oh I'm sorry
are there questions are you taking
questions are you are there questions
from the committee man I am not a good
chair today I am like the worst no I ran
election law like a machine yesterday
and today I was just like yeah no all
right uh next up thank you so much next
Up's representative Katie uh Perell
peterel Pell oh next bill I'm sorry then
don't give don't give me these cards so
early I told you these cards so early no
that's 584 that's next bill all right
next up then is Shannon
Trimble
good afternoon thank you my name is
Shannon Trembley I'm the director of the
childcare advisory Council however today
I'm here on behalf of a fellow resident
of Hampton New Hampshire who um tried to
open a child care business um Hampton is
a well populated town however we only
have 206 licensed spots for child care
um and probably only a quarter of those
are you know being able to be open now
um so this is from Abigail Gavin uh
Galvin sorry I'm writing this letter in
support of HB 1567 that allows for
residential homes to open child care
facilities in June of 2023 I bought a
new house not only to be my primary
resident residence but also for the
purpose of opening an inhome daycare
business I spent months renovating and
preparing the space so that it would be
ready for by the beginning of the school
year in September I worked with
childcare license licensing health and
building inspectors to make the space
safe and reliable for child care after
in investing a significant amount of
money and time I went to the zoning
board where it was shut down along with
the zoning board members disagreeing
with the business multiple neighbors
wrote letters complaining about a
business being opened in their
residential neighborhood these neighbors
were unaware of the child care crisis
that is happening in our town State and
Country and also unaware that in inhome
daycare is much is a much different type
of business one that does not create an
additional burden to on the neighbors
not only did I quit my regular job as a
public school teacher to B to provide
the service for the community I also had
parents who were relying on me for child
care for their child there is a
desperate need for child care in my town
we are looking to provide parents with a
safe Comfort comfortable place for their
children to learn and grow in our town
like many towns in New Hampshire we are
in a daycare desert where there are no
available options for family in need of
child care centers have a long wait list
and families are left with having to
make choices about staying home to care
for their children or entering the
workforce we need more reliable child
care options and allowing inhome
daycares is a great place to start this
is why I feel very passionate about
zoning boards being more flexible when
it comes to people trying to open child
care businesses in residential areas
without access to child care parents are
unable to work and that is negative
affecting our economy and people's lives
I hope this letter will be strongly
considered in your decisions going
forward thank you for your time signed
to Abigail G
Galvin thank you um so first thing will
you be taking
questions as much as I can I can answer
my question is can we have the letter
absolutely yes I only have one copy but
yes you're welcome to it sure represent
cre will take good care of it but yes we
will want a copy of that for sure um
especially as that's horrible
um questions from the committee okay
seeing none thank you so much and just
hand the letter representative page um
that's that's a good one and our last up
is our own Jen
leier it's good to see you
Jen
okay hi my name is Jennifer leer and I'm
in exitor New Hampshire and I have the
joy and pleasure to be um in the
franchising space for child care and
we've really um come to establish small
family child care centers across the
state oh sorry I have handouts um it's
really become an area of focus for us
and well that I'm enjoying very much and
there's a lot of room for growth in the
area sorry I'm going hand these
out
there should be one per person in
there so while those are being handed
out I do have um another letter of
testimony from plasto New Hampshire from
another family care provider she
couldn't be here today because
shockingly she's working um I can read
it into testimony or I can hand it in
but it really Echoes the same
conversation that Abby had um do you
want me to go into this letter I think
um I think I know how this one's going
to shake out so not to be like rude but
in the interest of time y I'll will take
the letter um I will I will read it but
I think uh I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised so I think the I think the
resounding message from this particular
letter is that she was able to set up a
commercial Child Care space in three
weeks family child care took over six
months and thousands of
dollars in her home okay so
obviously we understand why we're here
you know this is an accessory use for
your house that already exists you know
legislating things like you know can you
have a fenced in front yard versus
backyard there's there's so many like
nitpicky things that towns have started
to kind of come up with that really keep
family child care from opening in their
town if you look at the regions with
gaps Hampton is a big area we looked at
a 10 mile radius in these circles
there're zero family childcare providers
there's 349 spaces that are available
that people need to fill conquered three
pages of legislation like for Family
Care Providers it's very hard to open
and conquered shockingly no providers
626 spaces that need to be filled and
conquered as a gap Berlin small area
this is where Family Care is really
important these small communities they
can't sustain centers of a hundred they
need family child care here within a 20
mile radius zero Family Care Providers
87 spaces needed Keen 10 mile radius no
providers 215 spaces really took this
data from across the entire State
there's no one region that's not
affected by this it's the entire state
so there's 22,000 licensed Child Care
spaces that are needed across the state
of New Hampshire two in five children
are working in Working Families in New
Hampshire don't have access to licensed
childcare where their parents are at
work do we want them in licens exemp
child care or in Babysitting like or
care providers who have to lie no we we
want these environments to be safe for
our children and know that they're going
to be available consistently a rich and
diverse array of child care options
should be available to these families
which support Family Choice and child
care services some children are not
going to succeed in a center of a 100
they need small more Hands-On learning
environments with that that smaller
ratio of you know six children with with
one provider it gives parent choice
evenings weekends times that they need
or more convenient for their child's
style of learning So Family Care is a
really important role for our families
um like Chuck said they provide flexible
hours nights weekends small personal
learning environments in the tuition
let's be honest the reimbursement rate
is lower for family child care tuition
is usually lower because you don't have
the overhead of all the commercial space
so it is a really important choice for
some of our families in struggl regions
um and as Chuck said I don't know if he
had the same number but the economic
impact in New Hampshire from this child
care Gap is $262
million this is too large of a number to
ignore this this problem so that's it
okay well we been taking questions yes
are questions from the committee seeing
none thank you um last up is Michelle
Merritt Merill Merritt
there no no no you definitely did it's
uh the glasses aren't doing much these
days thank you Mr chair honorable
members of the committee again my name
is Michelle Merritt I'm the president at
new futures for those that are not
familiar with our organization we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization doing Statewide
policy work however we also are the
state's designated kids count
organization and have been bringing
forward data informed policy solution to
some of our most pressing challenges and
those in the child care space is one um
Jen obviously I think hit all of the
points so I want to appreciate the
committee's time um I do just want to
again reiterate that 46% of children in
New Hampshire live in a child care
desert and while we can look at our
child care centers and they're doing a
lot to try to close the gap in the
number of slots that we need in order to
meet demand from families they cannot
possibly fill that void on their own um
there is no silver bullets solution to
the child care crisis but this is one
important strategy of supporting family
and small group uh facilities that I
think is an important step for us to
take as a state to make it a more
hospitable environment for those that
want to establish Child Care Centers and
um become child care providers in this
state so I'll I'll leave it at that but
if there are any questions I'm happy to
take them and again would Echo the
comments from those prior to me right
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you
can we grab the yes Municipal
Association does not this bill oh that's
that uh if if they did I would be more
likely to vote for
it they uh they they tried to block me
getting rid of the um $2 filing fee
saying that would have a fiscal for
State reps having it would have a fiscal
impact on the town I to Lobby so I was
like are you serious like for real with
this um anyways all right uh we've got
online um seven signed up in support one
in
opposition um on the blue
sheet we have do
math two
three four five we had five people
signed up not speaking all in
support um with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 1567
and pursuant to the rules uh if the
ranking member agrees we can immediately
exec this bill um so representative
walner do you agree to open executive
session on House Bill
1567 I agree okay um is there any
discussion on House Bill 1567 from the
committee okay uh when the clerk is
ready the clerk will call the role on
House Bill
representative like pop that open oh I'm
sorry we we need to do this the right
way uh we need to do this the right way
representative wner is recognized to
make a
motion my
apologies I'll move ought to
pass representative D Simone seconds now
we are now we can discuss the bill and
now since seeing no discussion now the
clerk can call the role I totally got
that right to say as someone
who as someone whose kids went to a I
don't know if it was technically an
inhome daycare but it was really just
like right down the street from us and
in our community it was great to be able
to walk them so I am fully in support of
this okay all right we are now in the
voting mode the clerk will call the RO
on the motion of ought to pass Vice
chairman
yes representative Phils yes
representative B yes
no she's not here
representative
yes
yes you got I I would like to vote oh
I'm
sorry the chair votes yes uh and with
that the bill reported out of committee
on a vote of 8 to zero um can I just say
one thing of course I didn't want to
interrupt the voting mode but I want to
thank representative grassy one of my
major concerns with child
care is the fact that kids need child
care for parents who work 3 to 11 11 to
7 7 to 7 and whatever other hours and
this is one of those
answers and they have people who love
them who care for them in their homes
and this is a that's why it's so easy to
pass this Bill thank you yeah this was a
great one good job representative grassy
all right um I will handle the committee
report if unless anybody has objections
to that um and oh it's a fiscal note so
we will vote on it on the floor um okay
that was easy see it makes up for my
earlier embarrassment right all right um
going to open up the public hearing on
House Bill
1584 um relative to home daycare
licensing requirements uh representative
now now you're representative now you're
here a repres I'm a representative I
wasn't five minutes ago you're still
representative now you're now you're
here to introduce the bill um welcome to
the special committee on Child Care
thank you good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee um for the
record Katie Pell representing Carol
district 6 wolfboro and Tuftonboro I am
here to present House Bill 1584 relative
to home daycare licensing and the idea
for this legislation was presented to me
as a possible way to increase access to
child care without taxpayer funding um
and this is actually kind of personal
for me because my daughter is using one
of these situations because we could not
find daycare for my granddaughter in our
own community in fact she's been on the
waiting list for over a year they just
called her recently and said would you
like to contining she said just forget
it um so this is
really increasing access to daycare is
really important and I'm acutely aware
of this situation so it's obviously
unnecessary for me to delve too deeply
into it because that's why your
committee is formed um but this bill
amends RSA
17-e colon 3 Roman numeral 1 C by
increasing the number of children that
who can be cared for in a private home
in addition to the PRI providers own
children from the three children to four
children this RSA is in the exemption
section of the child care licensing
statute um the ratio of providers to
Children is not affected by this change
as the providers are not a licensed home
daycare um the minimum of ratio for
infants in a licensed setting I believe
is 1 to three and a home daycare has the
flexibility to determine the ages of the
children he or she is willing or able to
care for um as well as setting their own
limit up to a Max maximum of four
children should this bill pass um there
are benefits to a home daycare setting
that representative D Simone just spoke
to a few minutes ago you flexibility
nights evenings weekends those kind of
things um I also see a huge benefit um
to home dayare as someone who wasn't
always a personal fan of daycare um when
my own own children were in daycare I
chose a s a setting that was more
similar to what they would have
experienced at home so multiple children
of different ages in a setting where
they could you know learn not just from
their peers but from older children
which not not always the best but
sometimes it works um uh so but the
children are in a home and that's really
important to me um and but they can
possibly see family interactions and
typical events that occur in a home such
as cooking laundry chores Etc I know my
granddaughter gets to see her friend
Maddie get off the bus every day when
she comes home from school and stands
outside waiting for her so it's kind of
kind of a kind of fun uh so this could
be a more convenient location also for
parents as pickup and drop off add to
the work commute you know if the only
child care center is 30 minutes the
other direction from work now you've got
a commute of an hour on either end of
the day and we all know that that extra
time could be spent doing spent in more
valuable ways with your own children um
maybe the CH child or the parents are
more comfortable with a family member or
a friend that they know um and it might
also be offered a more already said that
um and it could be less expensive my um
daughter's daycare is less expensive
than the local children's center um and
the downsides you know parents need to
do their own homework to vet the inhome
day care and ask the right questions and
I in preparing for this I asked my
daughter I said what what questions did
you ask and she said I probably should
have asked a few more but so we went
through the list of questions she would
should have asked and it's all turning
out fine but you know looking back she's
young and didn't really wasn't fully
aware of all of the questions she should
be looking into um and then if the
provider is ill or has appointments that
might mean time off work for the parent
you know you have to find find somebody
else to care for the child and that
happened to me this morning and I said
nope I have to be here to vote today so
sorry I can't help you out so I hope you
consider supporting House Bill 1584 as a
simple non- taxpayer funded way to
increase access to child
care okay uh will you be taking
questions from the committee I will try
to answer any are there questions from
the
committee seeing none um thank you so
much thank you next up is representative
Margaret
dry
welcome to the house special committee
on Child Care thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for having me um for the
record I'm representative Margaret dry I
serve Sullivan district 7 uh Newport
Unity Charlestown planfield and
Cornish and I'm here today um for a
couple of reasons well one I'm on the
education committee so we hear uh child
care as a coraly to a lot of the um re
um Recruitment and retaining uh of not
only teachers but also staff and uh in
the last few months I also served on the
commission for hospitality and tourism
education in New Hampshire it was a
commission um meant to to figure out
what we do in the state and again uh
Child Care and housing came up as
corollary problems to expanding the
tourism and the hospitality industry so
um this bill seemed like um uh one of
the pieces of the puzzle it's a there's
a lot of pieces in solving the puzzle
but this might be an easy one to put in
to into circulation second is I my
husband and I raised nine children and I
always got this question how did you do
that and my answer is always one at a
time and uh and that's kind of how this
is Sol attempting to solve this problem
moving from three to four children I
found personally isn't you're already in
zone defense at that point and so adding
one more isn't that hard to do and um
and I think that would have been um been
helpful in our town in planfield over
this weekend I don't know if you read
that the the Campbell Union Academy uh
Child Care had to be closed because of
lead poisoning they found some sick
children and uh and close that now that
that's for the faculty the staff and
community members so all of a sudden
there's a big need in my town and if
this this um was ready this you know
reserve of an extra space in some
people's homes they may not have filled
it at that point that might have helped
to solve I know a lot of families that
this weekend had a big scramble so
that's why I'm asking you to support
this Bill thank you excellent will you
be taking questions from the committee
absolutely sure are there questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you okay
thank you um last up at least for the
last pink card that I have um is uh Jan
leir
shocking that you're seeing me again I'm
sorry Jen leer exitor New Hampshire
um I my one concern about this as I do
kind of go through the licensing process
pretty regularly is that um the fire
codes and I'm reading them right here do
only allow for three children in um
Family Daycare homes that are not
related so
this kind of becomes a fire code related
issue and are there waivers that have to
kind of come into fire code for this in
conversations with them they're because
a family child care that's licensed
exempt like this doesn't have to go
through zoning and they don't have to go
through the regulatory sign off in these
processes so bringing in four children
would they probably wouldn't even be
aware of the fact that they were not
following fire codes um because there's
no checks and balances for a license
exemption Center so it would follow the
responsibility of the owner of that
particular license exemp center to to
follow the fire code so I think it it
opens them up to
liability if we're not following the
fire code and it's a a selfcheck in
balance that they're responsible for
it's a lot like you know our staff who
can't manage their money right that we
were talking about an earlier testimony
um so I have some reservations about
this you know as as an owner myself so
will you be taking questions from the
committee absolutely are there questions
from the committee representative
cretians are recognized thank you chair
thank you for taking my question um
might have almost been a question for
the previous uh testifier who said one
at a time um I'm a little concerned that
this doesn't have any information in it
about the ages of the additional
children who are cared for um do you see
that as a as a problem with your
experience um yeah I mean in family
child care there's you know ratios from
childcare licensing perspective you can
only have two children under the age of
two with no regulation because of
ability to evacuate you know the Melissa
will tell you you know it's two children
under the age of two so if you're
getting out of the building it's one
child here one child here and you walk
out the door with two children in a
licensed exempt setting you wouldn't
have that regulation where you could say
you know only two children under two so
it could be um all four infants it could
all school agers I mean who who knows um
so I do think that if it's not
regulated correctly there could be some
safety concerns that evolve here I mean
we have four infants in a license center
but we have evacuation cribs and there's
extra staff members even if we went to
four infants in a a a family care home
you would still have to have certain
procedures in place to be able to
evacuate correctly but we're asking for
these centers who are license exempt to
follow rules that they don't have to
follow they're not even aware of them so
I I think that's my concern is
that yeah they don't even know these
rules exist
yeah okay awesome um any further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you so much um can we grab that
blue
sheet um and then online we have uh six
signed in support one signed in as a
post um and I need the I need that
magical blue sheet
yeah how dare you how dare you how do
you sleep at night
Sir
okay all right signed up but not
speaking
um only had one was signed up that
didn't speak um okay so with that uh
we'll close the public hearing on
1584 um we are now moving into our
notice to Executive session I did see so
I'm going to gav gavel um going to open
up the executive session the noticed
executive session for let me get to the
bill before I put my foot in my mouth uh
House Bill 1611 FN uh I did see a email
come in from
OS um so let's put the committee into
recess for five minutes and we'll
probably recess again after that just to
get that amendment in hand um and figure
out where representative MC Williams
is how how dare she oh my
God okay all right so I tell you what
let's just recess for 10 minutes um and
um I will
um I will send the bill off to HCS for I
probably just send it to Carrie
Karen
okay we are back we are back we are back
we are back all right going to reopen
the executive session on House Bill
1611 uh representative D Simon is
recognized for a motion on House Bill
1611 uh I'm
moving to turn my micone on yeah it's
for the kids at home
uh thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move Amendment got we have do an OTP
motion first I would like to move OTP
thank you we have an OTP motion on House
Bill 1611 is there a second looks like
representative crean seconds um are
there any amendments it does appear
there's an amendment um represent Deon
would you like to move the amendment I
would like to do that did they give it a
number I would like like to move
Amendment uh yeah you'd like to move
Amendment yeah
number 2024
d562 H excellent is there a second on
Amendment 2024
0562 H second representative MC Williams
second the amend we are now on
discussion on the amendment is there
discussion on the
amendment hearing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion on the
amendment 2024 0562
H
yes yes representative ball yes
representative walner
yes clerk votes yes representative MC
Williams yes representative O'Neal yes
representative Paige yes and Mr chair
you're missing one uh representative
representative Sweeney is subbing in for
representative Nelson oh
okay sorry I didn't see you over there
representative he's not just here for
his yes all right and the chair votes
yes so with that uh the amendment
carries 10 to nothing we are now the
motion is now ought to pass as amended
we are in discussion on the bill as
amended is there discussion on House
Bill 1611 FN as
amended hearing none the clerk will call
the
role I to read
it uh representative deimon yes
representative Phillips yes
representative ball yes representative
Sweeney yes representative walner yes
clerk votes yes representative MC
Williams yes representative O'Neal yes
representative Paige yes and Mr chairman
the chair votes yes and with that uh
House Bill 1611 will be reported out of
the committee as octop pass as amended
uh representative Mick Williams is going
to go ahead and take care of our
committee report for us without
objection um it cannot go on a well I
it's can't go on a consent calendar
anyways because it has a fiscal note so
we'll have two bills when these get
reported down that concludes our
business for today I want to thank the
committee for working so nicely together
and um I will notice probably executive
session in two weeks um so if we have
discussions on these things reach out
now and we'll get done thank you guys so
much they don't clap for me like that in
election you see some boo not going to
lie